e
open the hearing on House Bill
285 on parental rights and
responsibilities an additional section
is um
were asked for by
the um Prime sponsor who is not here oh
yes he made it is here wow so when
you're done blowing your nose please
good morning chairman Pearson and the
children and family law committee um
please pardon my expance it was really
windy walking here and I do not have a
hairbrush with me um some of us don't
need a hairbrush which so
lucky are so lucky
um I come forward to ask you to consider
House Bill
285 it's on the surface um a simple
clarification it's not even a
clarification it just adds words to
remind judges to make sure that they're
looking at a full environment for
children and it asks judges to look at
as another Factor any known mental
health um conditions that could
interfere with parenting in no way am I
advocating for judges to ask for private
information or to disclose counseling or
to um give over medical record records
however for a judge to truly make a
determination in the best interest of
the child they need to understand the
Full Ecology um and environment of the
home
situation as we know or many of us know
um divorce is one of the biggest
stressors that a person
can um have in their
lifetime and that includes the custody
determinations it includes ch es often
of employment households I mean these
are the biggest stressors that we face
as
adults when you look at that and then
you compound that with one or both of
the parents having a known mental health
or even a medical condition that could
be aggravated by this stressor the judge
needs to be made aware of that and again
not looking to take children from
parents I'm looking to assure that the
children have a safe safe healthy
environment to go to when parents are
married they are very fortunate that
they have each other to pick up the
slack if one is not feeling well or one
is having um any kind of a mental or a
medical crisis they have a support
system but after the divorce these
systems can fall apart especially if the
divorce is not
amicable then we're sending home
children to home environment ments that
may not be in their best interest these
are young children now who have to
navigate a home
environment sometimes by acting like the
other parent and helping the the parent
they're with at that time to be able to
function again I cannot stress enough I
am not looking for private information I
am not saying the judge I would hope our
judges would be well informed not to ask
for any personal invit um information
from the parents but simply ask a
question is there
anything that I should know when I make
a determination on parenting and that
could be as simple as and this might not
be the right thing to say but I'll say
it it could be as simple as
understanding that the parent um needs
to continue in counseling or needs to be
on medication or needs and that is up to
the parent to if they want to provide
that but the the judge needs to to know
this um in order to assure the safety of
the
child and I'm open to taking questions
I'm sorry I'm running here so late and
um so I'm a little
discombobulated well we hope you will be
combobulated thank you I think so um
would you believe that in almost 50
years of uh being a clergy member I've
had numbers of of families where there
were mental health issues but that did
not necessarily impact their ability to
parent well that I would put there there
being somewhat of a spectrum of ability
and inability mental health issues by
themselves not being a determinative
would you believe I would absolutely um
believe that and agree with that I think
that
this um what we're adding in would be
adding into this bill would just provide
the opportunity for a judge to ask a
question no more than that um I
certainly um know
of many people who may have challenges
medical physical emotional challenges
who are very good parents and I'm not
trying to sit here and say that just
because you have challenges in your life
doesn't mean you can't
parent but if those challenges do
interfere then we need to have a
mechanism to make sure that the judge
knows that and so that he can make an
appropriate um decision as far as the
best interest of the child and would you
further believe that since this as you
describe it is simply reminder the
extremely well-crafted amendment that I
have in my hand um would spells that out
exactly to say that mental medical or
mental health condition that could
aversely affect a person's ability to
parent is a further yet further reminder
to a judge what he or she already knows
I would definitely agree with that any
other
questions representative Raymond uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative ball for coming back to
our committee um so my question is about
um the the whole passage that you're
quoting 461 A6 has a through M and so a
is that the judge has to consider I'm
I'm sorry B and C uh B A says that the
judge has to consider the ability of
each parent to provide the child with
nurture love affection and guidance and
B is the ability of each parent to
assure the child receives adequate food
clothing shelter Medical Care and a safe
environment and so my question is why
wouldn't that um prescription the
prescriptions that the judge already
consider the parents ability to provide
these things for the children not cause
the judge to look at things that would
interfere with their ability like I
guess I'm I'm confused about how this
language um increases the focus on the
best interest of the child as opposed to
looking for reasons why a parent
wouldn't be able to
parent thank you for your question I
believe that many of us are are aware of
the revolving door in family court with
the judges and even though we are
supposed to have one family one judge it
doesn't happen and there are people that
have certain mental illnesses who can
present themselves as
very um thoughtful caring parents they
can present that once but then when they
come back to the court the next time and
the next time and the next time the
judge starts saying a pattern of
behavior that indicates there could be a
mental health issue um happening here
but since we don't always have the same
judge a judge is not aware of that and a
person wouldn't present that way and the
other parent is not allowed to present
any evidence in court and so therefore
how do you get this information to the
judge unless the judge can actually ask
the
question followup thank you Mr chairman
so what about those parents who clearly
have mental health issues but have
chosen not to seek mental health
counseling or a diagnosis for themselves
how does a judge determine that based on
this language well it's my understanding
um that the judge can order
psychological evaluations if he sees fit
um but this would open the door for him
to ask the question and determine
whether or not something should be uh
looked at more closely I think it also
opens the door for the the other parent
to provide testimony um and evidence
that may indicate that the parent um may
have lapses in their ability to parent
their child again not meaning that that
parent should not have custody of that
child but that just that there may need
to be guard rails put into place to
assure that that parent um is seeking
the help that they need in order to be
representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman I was
wondering if I was going to get called
on there for a second uh and thank you
and I will echo my uh the sentiments
from our other colleague it's nice to
see you back in here again um my
question is understanding the
weaponization in these high conflict
cases of stuff like mental health and
you know how that works how is this to
be known because there are a lot of
accusations in high conflict cases of
even in abuse cases of oh well this
person isn't unfit or that they're unfit
because maybe they were depressed while
going through that or whatever else but
I just am confused as to what the basis
is on how it would be known
understanding that that becomes very
weaponized in court thank you for your
question and it's interesting that you
bring up the weaponization within family
court because that is one of the biggest
challenges in family court and it
happens before Family Court when systems
are weaponized like making false
allegations against another parent and
those allegations can often be made by
the parent who actually has the uh
Mental Health Challenge and so they're
not looking to look for the best
interest of their child they're looking
to win at all costs that is part of
their um mental health disorder or
challenge um saying that this would
weaponize it I think it actually takes
that weapon away from weaponizing it
within the family cour because you can't
weaponize something if it doesn't exist
and if the
person you know it you have to look at
the whole dynamic and I think by asking
the question is what disarms both
parents from weaponizing the parent the
uh family court because it is now put
right out there we can't hide behind
anything we can't make false allegations
we can't just do things in Family Court
to try and get the result
that we want and I think that this helps
the judge
determine where the truth is in
determining where the best interest of
the child
lies followup and is there something
right now that is keeping the judge from
being able to weigh on this at
all well when I spoke to uh
representative Lynn when I wrote this up
um and he was a superior court judge
suprem higher Supreme Court judge so I
did run this by him and his response to
me was there is no problem with a judge
asking a question my concern is the I
would like to see that there because my
experience is and hearing from my
constituents is the judges do not ask
the question that that is never put out
there there is never an opportunity to
um share the whole um home environment
with the judge as I said in Family Court
you can't provide any evidence so even
if the other parent has evidence that
this parent may not I I love my ex like
my soon to be ex I love that person but
the person may not have the wherewithal
by themselves to be able to parent um in
a in the best possible manner in the
best interest of the child and I'm not
looking to keep my child from them but I
need to be assured that that parent is
going to get what they need to help them
be the best possible parent that's what
I'm hoping this will do is allow the
judge to maneuver his way through this
web and and determine what is in the
best interest of children and how do we
best meet the parents of both parents as
you know I was a huge advocate for
approximately equal parenting time so I
am no way am looking to lessen the
amount of time a child spends with a
parent what I am looking to do is
provide a mechanism for judges to um
have the guard rails put in place to
assure that the child is the
determinations are in always in the best
interest of the
child representative
love thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned that
uh you know the revolving judge thing
and I I I think it's got a lot to do
with burnout myself these are tough
cases and uh they must have a tough time
but anyway um in your bill here uh do
you think it might be uh advantageous to
amend it to to have direct instruction
for the judge to ask these
questions well I think um thank you for
the CH the
question I think just putting the
reminder there to the judge that that is
another factor that they should consider
um I don't think they have to be
directed to do it if they don't um I
trust our judges uh to do what is right
and to ask the questions that are
appropriate this would only serve as a
reminder that we are looking at the
whole picture and not just these little
parts of the picture thank
you representative
Sher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for uh your uh what you've said so far
I'm a little uh I think I'm beginning to
understand what is it my understanding
that judges could ask questions about
known mental health conditions now but
they
don't is that what you're saying well
thank you for the question my experience
from watching The Family Court um and
from the input that I'm receiving from
my constituents is that the judges do
not ask and there is no opportunity for
them to present any evidence that a
parent may need to have some guidelines
or um guardrails put into the parenting
plan to ensure that that parent can
continues to receive the adequate um or
the necessary care to parent effectively
follow up thank you um uh I'm not Fami
very familiar with family court but
um is isn't it the case that one of the
parties if they so choose could say I'm
concerned about my child spending so
much time with this parent who I believe
has a mental illness can't they already
say
that thank you for the child the uh the
parent my experience has been um that
although that is supposed to be taken
into consideration the parent cannot
bring it up because then they would be
presenting evidence again and they would
have to show they can't just make an
allegation in the court and even if they
had the evidence they can't provide it
unless the other parent is on the stand
and opens the door for that evidence to
come in for instance um in the I mean we
we went last year and we watched many
cases um but in and then my constituents
as I said and from what I'm hearing is
that unless the parent on the stand
brings something up
um the question can't be made um so if a
if a parent was to bring up I don't know
I'll just give a for instance they
happen to
mention Facebook well that's an
opportunity for the other lawyer to say
oh you mentioned Facebook gez have you
seen what's posted on Facebook and
that's how you open it but that lawyer
could not just say did you post these on
Facebook they have to wait for the door
to be opened in order to get that
information in that's has been my
understanding that's what I'm hearing
from many constituents and that I'm just
pulling that out of the top of my head
but
um does that answer your question I'm
sorry uh close enough I think I'm okay
uh I I do I don't know enough about
family well let me remind you or fill
you in on what we found out last year or
the last two terms 80% of the uh parents
that are in Family Court are
prosay so they don't have the
wherewithal to know how to get this
information to the judge and so the
judge needs to kind of steer the um the
case and the court into the direction to
make sure he gets all the information he
needs to make an absolute education best
decision for the best interest of the
child and for those other 20% those are
typically um I won't say typically
because maybe that's not the case but
they have attorneys who know how to
maneuver the family court and know how
to get evidence in and know how to get
this information before the judge my
concern is on those other 80% and maybe
there they might be the 80% that don't M
matter maybe it's just the 20% of high
volatile cases that really need to have
this brought forward but we never seem
to be able to get it there and that's
what I'm trying to make sure that the
judge actually has something in writing
that says I'm allowed to ask this
question I'm not going to ask you for
any of your medical records I'm not
going to ask you for your counseling
records all I want to know is there
anything I should be aware of that might
interfere with your ability to parent
thank
you representative George thank you Mr
ch um thank you
for your concern um I'm not just like
ask a question but um I think so you
you're doing something that very good
for kids uh I've been there and I
understand everything what you say for
to understand for parent for to be um
for the ability especially for the
mental health thank you anyone else
final
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question representative ball
uh
to add on a a previous comment from one
of the members um relative to the the
judge asking this question in the
narrative when it
states if the the court deems
relevant or de facto the judge could
deem it not relevant even before it's
even brought up in my interpretation of
that should should language not be where
it is a requirement uh for lack of a
better word that the judge would ask for
this type of information and knowing
that evidence apparently can't be
accepted unless it's um a context is
offered within a within a
narrative thank you for asking that
question I will mention that there are
several other states that already have
this in their law that it is required to
for the judge to take this into
consideration and to ask the question
um I think the point of then the judge
if the judge has that information then
they can deem whether or not it's
relevant is it going to interfere with
the parents ability to parent um but
they they can't make that determination
if they don't have the information to
begin with just follow up follow up
thank you Mr chairman uh just a follow
up on this then it would be the
representation outside of a prosay but a
representation of the
petitioner that
this information would be then provided
which would then have the judge
responding to it that' be the only other
alternative because the judge could not
could D now just say it's not relevant
it doesn't come up in in court the begin
with well it's that's an interesting
question thank you because it does bring
up the the point and as I'm thinking and
I thought about it this morning of
mandated reporting if the judge ask the
question
are the parents then not mandated to
report whether or not they have seen
situations where um the child was not
being parented correctly or in the best
interest of the child so this would be
something that would have to open the
door um and get that information to the
judge am I understanding your question
correctly I I well it's it's a debating
Point okay right now I just just to load
to follow up on one of them is is the
term relevant is it transfers the
responsibility then specifically to the
judge to
decide whether it's relevant or not
unless it's in the narrative to State
you shall as as opposed to May uh ask
for for this information and to follow
your guidance uh the ultimate Authority
here is the safety of the of the CH of
the children and possibly the other
adult as well so that's why I was I was
wondering whether um the the relevancy
would require an
additional uh sentence to State you you
shall ask on this subject or there could
be others added to
it I appreciate your um question when I
wrote this it was to try and keep it in
a simple just it started with just other
factors to include and so it's just one
of those things to just throw out the
reminder that there is more than just
looking at what's on the surface we need
to look at what's underneath the surface
as well that was the intent when I wrote
it if it would need to be amended I
would be more than uh happy to work with
the committee on an amendment or you
know the committee can amend it as they
see fit thank you representative B thank
you Mr
chairman anything else any other
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
to the entire committee I appreciate
your time in considering this Bill thank
you the chair recognizes Sarah H horn oo
I was watching Boston Sports last night
I apologize Sarah horn who wants to
speak for three minutes and
handouts good morning chairman Pearson
and committee members um thank you so
much for the opportunity to testify
today um my name is Sarah horn I am a
Nami New Hampshire board member and in
our own voice presenter um I live in
Manchester however I'm not testifying in
my capacity as Nami today I'm testifying
as a um resident and parent um I'm here
today to speak in opposition of Bill
285 so at a young age I was diagnosed
with obsessive compulsive disorder by
the time I turned age 13 this disorder
significantly impacted my ability to
function in my daily living skills
getting out of bed every morning was
extreme daunting um I knew that I would
be living in fear all day um constantly
completing rituals to try to minimize
that fear um I couldn't see that it
could get any better and at the age of
13 I came home from school and I tried
to take my own life for the next four
years of my adolescence I had six
hospitalizations and a residential
placement in addition to OCD I also live
with attention deficit disorder and
post-traumatic stress
disorder I was extreme fortunate that I
had supportive parents that stopped at
no end to help me get the resources that
I needed to have a successful
recovery I share this with you today um
because I'm a senior HR business partner
at a local nonprofit and I've held this
position for 19 years um I serve on two
boards in the community and the role
that I am most proud of is that I am a
mom to a three-year-old boy I improved
Pro that recovery is possible and that
my history of mental illness has no
bearing on my ability to parent um if
anything because of my experiences I
more patient empathetic resilient in my
parenting and I hope that I pass all of
those traits on to my son I know what I
need to do to keep myself well um and I
am actively focused on
that my concerns are that this bill will
allow for further discrimination and
damaging stigma I could only imagine how
difficult and emotional a parental
rights um custody hearing could be for
somebody um and my concern is that if
this bill should pass it would deter
people from seeking the mental health
counseling or support that they need um
to keep themselves
well I asked that instead you focus on
active and current behaviors of the
parents not a health history because we
are not our Di
nosis for these reasons I respectfully
ask the committee to vote opposed to
much thank you for your testimony would
you believe it
is this kind of testimony that prompted
me to file the amendment so that if the
amendment passes the bill would read not
only mental health but physical health
as well so that the spotlight isn't on
one thing and that could avert verely
affect a person's ability to parent it
sounds like you're a Victor MH and it
your history does if anything informs
your parenting right but it not does not
hurt it correct so with the additional
language of the amendment um uh would
you believe that would take away some if
not all of the uh
stigma no because I I think
that health history how long ago could
this be right and and I think that any
of that has could have no impact on your
ability to par and I think when we take
into consideration health and mental
health I think we need to focus more on
what are the current inactive behaviors
of that um not what has happened in the
past or what is on a label would you
consider that a condition
today I'm sorry would you consider the
past um difficulty you mentioned
condition now that yes it's an active
diagnosis that I'm um very upfront about
um and you know making sure that I'm
keeping myself well I'm always in active
treatment because I think that's what
you need to do um to continue to keep
yourself well um so the fact that if I
were to ever be in this situation for
them to take into consideration that I
was actively seeking supports that
continue to keep myself well in my
recovery um and that could be held
against me um that's concerning
any further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you so much chair recognizes Uh
Kevin
Blanchett who asks to speak for two
three hello thank you Representatives
I've also provided written testimony
online as well uh but it was a little
bit longer and I wanted to respect your
time today so uh my name is Kevin
Blanchett I'm a licensed clinical Mental
Health counselor here in the state of
New Hampshire I am I'm speaking today to
oppose this bill uh while I appreciate
the um concern we have for our children
in reading the current language of the
law I believe that it fully represents
the um care of the children it considers
factors of the school system that your
children child is in and if they have to
move to uh school systems the care the
child has the ability to receive from
each parent the um it considers abuse uh
potential abuse for to the towards the
child or towards the parents uh these
are things that we are concerned about
adding mental health to this list just
stigmatizes mental health and presumes
somebody having a mental health
condition makes them lesser of a parent
it means that there's things that they
cannot provide as a parent because of
their own mental health
struggles I had uh looked this up last
night and a report from the state in
2023 said that a quarter of uh people
living in New Hampshire have a mental
health illness I believe that is to be
larger portion of the population because
a lot of people do not come for
treatment and by not going to treatment
you are not going to receive a diagnosis
you're not going to be considered having
a mental health illness um even though
if you went to treatment you maybe would
then be considered that gives reason
this bill would give reason for people
to not seek treatment out of fear of how
it could be used against them if they
had a mental health illness I'm
concerned with that impact as a mental
health counselor I can tell you I
frequently write letters to the court
for people letting them know that this
person is in treatment um and so I am
frequently Asked these questions and
like asked to represent this and this is
frequently coming up in court for people
when it is a
consideration as the law has it now if
it is something to be considered the
judge is able to ask for it I recognize
that maybe the judges are not always
asking for that but then we should
really be considering is it how much of
a consideration is that or is it more
the behaviors that are being discussed
already in court that are the
consideration not the mental health um I
thank you for your
time would those with a medical
condition similarly not seek treatments
lest this become discovered and
therefore not seek treatment because of
that
I cannot really speak to that as I only
see people for mental health and not for
medical
conditions for a good answer any other
questions representative
love thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question wouldn't Hippa Hippa
covers a lot of this uh you know uh if
someone comes from mental health help uh
that Hippa does certainly you know keep
it private yes so it Hippa is in place
it does it keep private see a judge can
change that they can subpoena records
they can uh subpoena and they have the
clinician come and speak if they choose
so uh that provides a lot of stress and
planning on us as clinicians as we need
to get lawyers involved and not all
clinicians have will be doing that um to
the best of their abilities some
clinicians will still have questions
they may there's a lot of legal um
concerns that we have and how much do we
share how much do we not what can we
redact um or block out for the records
being um brought to court and um there
can be some like intimidation towards us
of we Rec courts really want everything
we want to try to limit that and
confusion questions come up from that
it's not cut and dry again if the judge
asks for this they currently can ask for
this this this would just make it that
the judge is more likely to be asking
for more information and presuming
mental health is a negative thing that
parenting representative George
thank um thank you for coming to
testify I just want to know do you know
there is a the people from mental health
who are Den iable you know that there is
a some they know they have a problem but
they don't
accept yes there's um many reasons for
people sometimes it is due to U concerns
that may come up that they do accept it
sometimes there's what's called
anosognosia which is a um symptom of
some mental health illnesses where a
person does not have the ability to
recognize their symptoms um even when
they are explained to the person they
their brain is not able to process it
they don't recognize
it follow thank you Mr chairman um when
I talk about deniable because there is a
I know some I know a couple who was
already like a the man is a with a
mental health already everything but in
the quote he said the wife who are
mental health and the Cote
believe the the guy the man and the wife
who's not never be in a question please
that's what I want to say for the
deniable do you do you believe like
those people can just make somebody else
a
problem uh so my concern is that that
they would be making somebody else a
problem and then now this person's
mental health is being considered um
when we're bringing mental health in it
can be a big Blame Game there can be a
lot of pointing fingers um we should not
be looking at a person's mental health
but their parenting their actions
behaviors things that have happened uh
which I believe the law as is currently
written does do thank
you anyone else saying none thank you
for your
testimony chair recognizes attorney
chairman Pearson members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify this morning my name is Holly
Stevens I'm the director of public
policy for Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness um I
here here today to speak in opposition
to House Bill
285 um as you um have read House Bill uh
285 allows the court to consider quote
any known mental health conditions of
the parent and that is how it's written
it's not the the amendment I understand
there is an amendment um as a factor
relevant uh to the determination or
parental rights and responsibilities
regardless of that condition's impact on
the person's ability to parent this only
furthers damaging stigma and jeopardizes
the rights of individuals living with
mental health conditions Simply Having a
mental illness like Simply Having a
other health condition in and of itself
does not inherently impact a person's
ability to parent their
child while one symptoms relating to
their condition May progress to a point
that impacts the parenting ability that
is not unique to mental
illness if a parent has untreated
epilepsy or diabetes they could have um
a period where they go unconscious and
are unable to care for their child um
there could be other medical conditions
as well that impair their ability to
parent if left
treated however this bill makes no
consideration for any health conditions
other than mental health conditions from
Nom New Hampshire's perspective
targeting a specific population of
individuals with mental illness without
any consideration of the conditions
impact on the parenting ability rather
than considering all health conditions
makes this policy
discriminatory with treatment and
support people are able to live full
successful lives as you heard um Sarah
horn talk about um
just the same someone with a chronic
health condition can live a full and
healthy life simply put no one should be
singled out because of their
diagnosis Beyond being discriminatory um
such this policy is also unnecessary you
heard um the the previous speaker talk
about the fact that all of these uh
factors can be considered already under
the law it's not necessary to call out
mental mental illness in and of itself
it is really looking at the parents
Behavior behaviors in their ability to
parent the
child um additionally um if there are
immediate concerns about a parent
ability to parent then you can call DCF
that's what they're there for if a
parents a symptoms start interfering
with their ability to parent their child
you can pick up the phone and call dcyf
and parenting plans take a long time to
so using the parent plan as a way to um
save a child from a parent's potential
um mental health conditions affecting
their ability to parent is not the best
way to go about this um I did include
some language that Nami New Hampshire
was okay with if the Committees um would
like to pass a bill which
says including due consideration for any
known health conditions that impact the
best interest of the child I know that
the
um Amendment says health conditions
including mental health that is
something we would still oppose because
it specifically calls out mental health
and shines a light on Mental Health
which we do believe is still
discriminatory um so for those reasons
we are opposing this bill today and we
would oppose the amendment as I heard
spoke are you familiar with the fact
that in other contexts
mental health is asked to be referenced
because the assertion is otherwise it is
forgotten and mental and health
conditions is assumed to be physical so
would you believe that I mean is that in
your
experience I think that one of the
things that we're trying to do is
educate people so that isn't the
experience I mean health conditions cons
contain mental health conditions and it
should be that way and maybe we need to
educate our judge Jes not change our
laws because if it's an issue with the
judges not asking the questions then
that's an education issue well as you
know I've been fighting for continuing
education for judges for some time and
will continue especially as long as my
wife has to do Boku amounts as a
physician so I'm with you on that let's
do that any questions for uh the
counselor representative
sh uh in in interest of full
transparency uh Miss Steven suffers from
the
uh Misfortune of having had classes from
me while at the law school so I just
want to make that clear up front are you
recusing yourself or recusing her
uh uh no answer to that question um so
is it you're welcome there's the Fifth
Amendment thing maybe you haven't gotten
that and then thank you thank you Mr
chair welcome no uh and thank you Miss
Stevens um is it nami's position that
just the name of a mental illness saying
that somebody suffers from ex mental
illness tells you nothing about the
quality of their parenting or their
ability to uh provide uh fit parenting
that is correct um even you know even
folks who may choose not to get
treatment it doesn't mean that that
their mental illness has any impact on
their ability to parent you really need
to look at their behaviors um not their
diagnosis and that is our position thank
questions represent you are so
backlighted it's just sort of wave uh
you were the new uh representative
Raymond this term uh representative
LC thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you um believe
that as a society today that there's
like this stigma around mental illness
that we have that it's seen as kind of a
definitive like that defines you versus
it's a part of you and it's not what
defines
you uh yes thank you for the question
yes we do believe that I mean one of the
things that Nami New Hampshire strives
for is to rid our society of stigma and
discrimination against people with
mental illness and one way that we do
that is by fighting against bills such
no further hands thank you so much thank
you chair recogniz is Karen
Rosenberg not to be confused with
Rosenberger which I do constantly and
you're a lawyer
correct are you one of his students no
okay you may continue thank you good
morning chairman Pearson members of the
committee I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center which is New Hampshire's
protection and advocacy system for
people with disabilities I'm here to
testify in opposition to this bill for
the reasons that you've heard from I
think uniformally from everyone um with
the exception of the bill sponsor of
course um we um see this as very
discriminatory um and furthering the
stigma of mental illness as you've heard
just because someone may have
experienced a mental illness either
currently or at some point in their
history doesn't mean that they are not
good parents or that they cannot be
effective Ive good parents and
so enacting a law that would single this
not even a particular condition but just
the fact that someone has experienced
some mental health condition at some
time we see as perpetuating
discrimination P perpetuating a stigma
and really not necessary our current law
is provides a list of factors that
courts must consider when they're
determining whether um a enabling a
parent to spend whatever amount of time
they decide they're going to spend with
their child is in the best interest of
the child or not and besides having this
list of factors which is you know quite
broad relationships with a child ability
of each child to parent the ch um to
provide nurturing love affection and
guidance I mean you've gone through the
list you've heard from other people
there's also broad discretion um for the
court to consider any other factor and
courts do ask unrepresented parties
questions I have not practiced in Family
Law Courts since a clinic in law school
but in my experience practicing law when
courts have questions they know how to
ask them and if there are concerns that
are raised courts can inquire of the
parties whether there are concerns about
parenting and I think that a parent who
is concerned that the co-parent is
potentially going to be harmful in their
parenting approach to the child they
will be able to raise that and the court
will be able to ask questions under our
current law
it's just not necessary um and
potentially harmful to single out mental
illness or really any physical illness
too because people manage both physical
illness and mental illness um all the
time and it doesn't necessarily impact
their parenting
abilities any questions for the witness
representative love thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um have having gone through a thing like
this and um you know not being able to
bring up mental illness uh I've got a a
25y old that's still in therapy today
it's it's a generational thing when when
bad things happen to kids uh they they
tend to stay a mess would you have any
suggestions for for um and and I do
believe in recovery from mental illness
by the way okay um do do you have any
suggestions that you could uh could give
us to to amend this um we've got this
one here uh you know just take the
mental part out of it and just Heth
questions but uh something needs to be
done because the courts are ignoring the
law I I well that may be if courts are
ignoring their obligation to make
rulings and ask questions to determine
whether a particular outcome is in the
best interest of a child that's a whole
other problem right our courts really
are in place we um nominate judges and
go through a process and there are Court
their evaluations of Judges after
they've been in office I mean that
that's a different kind of problem you
could pass any number of laws and if a
court is not following the law that's a
whole other problem I think the current
law is not the problem I think the
current law gives courts what they need
to make inquiries to determine whether a
a particular placement decision or
parental responsibility decision is in
would you second um attorney Stevens
statement that perhaps in the we hope
ever growing amount of continu excuse me
Ed the judges have there'd be a little
section on
this well you know certainly it would be
helpful for courts to be you know have
opportunities to be educated around what
are the factors that they need to
consider um when making these really
very important decisions that will
impact the life of a child thank you any
further questions representative
koser thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here to answer our questions
um I'm just wondering you may not even
have the answer I may have to ask dcyf
this but how many children are in DCF
custody or have been you know placed on
the adoptive track actually have parents
with with mental
illness you're correct I I don't have
sorry anyone else okay thank you for
your testimony thank
you chair recognizes former state
hearing you have been
card
okay I have called you to come
thank you for allowing me to address you
with my my feelings about this
bill first of all to me a child's needs
Trump a parent's needs hopefully we want
vulnerable this bill is to address
any known active current mental health
conditions of the parent that are
affecting their
parenting this bill is not interested in
a parent's mental health history that is
not
necessary
accommodation of the
illness can be uh can be made to
continue parenting as long long as we're
concerned that the par well I mean we
are concerned that the parenting is
healthy and a person with mental illness
who's being
treated and feels
good that that person is not a target of
this of the changes that we want to be
made the majority of states in the in
the US have laws that specify
consideration of current mental health
not the history of the health currently
New Hampshire law does not allow such
consideration and this certainly cannot
be initiated by the other
parent they are prohibited from bringing
up I would like this bill to be amended
to address the concerns that you're
bringing
up but the bottom line is the issue has
to be brought up in the consideration
for
parenting any parenting should be
considered that that's considered
wanting should be observable by other
people if they're really good if a
parent if a parent is really vindictive
and really unusual they can it from
other people but usually other people
are aware and are concerned for the
child when they observe negative
parenting some people are really good at
hiding it but I'd say that people in
court are generally going to believe
other people more so than the other
parent so it's really helpful if other
people are willing to stand up for that
child and testify on what they've
observed but they also have to be
permitted by the judge because that can
be denied under our current rules of
Family Court the the presiding
magistrate I don't use the term judge
easily because that's defin a definition
and we don't have that kind of judges in
family court so I'll say magistrate the
magistrate can choose not to have any
testimony not to have any evidence shown
so what we're asking for is that this
would be a requirement that they look at
look at uh other input if there is a
so okay so that that was my point number
five right now we cannot discuss that in
court unless by a little slip of the the
tongue by the other person to open the
door but only person with a really good
attorney would notice that so my
conclusion is please craft a bill
totally rewrite it that will protect
children from being raised by a parent
who consistently puts the child
criticism that's a really hard subject
to address and it is a very real issue
that we don't have adequate wording we
don't have adequate wording to address
right now may I ask you the question of
um where in the law is the things
prohibited so I can go look it up I can
know well I wish I wish I knew that it's
kind of hard to find things that are
missing um it would strengthen your
testimony when you say the law prohibits
if you tell us where to look it up
all I know is from practice from people
who've been through Court who are not
permitted who have not been permitted to
bring it up and certainly I can ask
questions and see if I can find which
RSA
subparagraph delineates that that would
be very helpful so what you are saying
if I get you correctly is the reason it
is not being brought up is in the Family
Division Vision The Rules of Evidence
are discretionary to the one presiding
at the hearing is that your testimony
that is true
okay the other part of your question I
don't I don't know if they did if they
did choose to allow the testimony where
would where would the prohibition be all
I know is in actual practice of the law
is not permitted thank you uh any other
questions for the former represent
resentative seeing none thank you and
research we will be executing this bill
it's been advertised uh two weeks from
today this closes the hearing on House
Bill
285 and we will execute in two weeks now
I'd like to open the hearing on House
and oh wow she
even she even changes the sign for
us um do you take coffee orders or Girl
Scout cookie orders or anything not if
you expect them to be for the record Mr
chair she doesn't change the sign in
house criminal J never
counselor
and oh uh representative
ball whoops we need a pink not unlike
the pink card you're already filling out
thank
you and uh we've got some stuff being
and we're going to need one for the vice
chair and pretty cards
and pretty
you actually it was the end of the table
good morning and the chair recognizes
representative n Murphy to distinguish
you from all the Murphy's yes thank you
good morning chairman Pearson and
honorable committee members for the
record I am representative Nancy Murphy
representing the town of marac I'm here
this morning to introduce HB 177 on
behalf of a constituent special ed
Advocate uh who discovered a need to
clarify some language relative to RSA
193 colon 27
HP 177 simply restores the reference to
RSA 193 colon 27 that was added through
HB 1511 but that was then essentially
removed when a second later bill hb1
1639 went into
effect two bills HB 1511 and HB 1639
were introduced uh and passed last year
both made changes to the same paragraph
of RSA 186c New Hampshire special ed law
uh with the first adding a reference to
RSA
19327 Roman numeral 8 episode of
treatment that was not in the second
bill um I reached out to O last in
August to make sure um that it was going
to be a a an uh a bill would be required
to correct this and um I was assured
that it would indeed be required that
that there was an oversight and that we
had to do this legislatively so I filed
the
LSR um on July 1st HB 1511 which amended
RSA 186c
190b um add a reference to RSA 19327
Roman Ral 8 the episode of treatment
went into effect just a few months later
on October 1st hb1
16639 which also amended RSA 186 C1 19B
went into effect so from July 1st till
October 1st the the language or 193
colon
277 which is the episode of treatment
was included in RSA 186 c19 B1 a then it
was removed or just miraculously
disappeared on October 1st when HB 1639
went into effect further compounding
things up till December 1st it remained
that way and now all of a sudden there's
change but not quite an exact change so
really this really simply is a
housekeeping bill which just clarifies
and
distinguishes U what the bill should say
um and I would ask that um you Pro i'
request an OTP recommendation and I
would thank you for your time for
helping end this circuitous
language
circuitous population
it is it is any
questions look I'm only a one L I'm glad
you gave me all of this stuff that's
really the reita digest version of the
whole thing with with the applicable
questions we are good and thank you and
you can watch History made if you care
to Jenny O Higgins signed a pink card in
case we need clarifications I think
we're
clarification but you can come on up and
it's
[Laughter]
billable good morning thank you I'm
Jenny O Higgins and the legislative Le
on for Behavioral Health at DHHS and
again was just an optional speaker to
provide info so we believed that the um
the the the the statute actually wasn't
really being changed because it already
is listed in here today so I think
hearing the the sponsor's testimony
helps to clarify that maybe it's been
removed and is looking to be Reed um we
do not
though episodes of treatment uh are not
court ordered so where this is placed is
somewhat confusing in terms of the
Department's um fiscal analysis of the
bill is that we they would not fall
under the statute to begin with so I
think that we could probably look
through the research presented today and
and talk with representative Murphy to
make sure we're all clear since I've
chaired DHHS oversight committee for the
last five years you guys are up to the
task of finding out what it means and
even if it
arguably rutly arguably is in the wrong
spot correct we will get to the bottom
of this I know it okay thank you for
your testimony thank you all right with
that I would like to close the hearing
on House Bill 177 and open the ex SE
session on that and the chair moves
ought to pass and second second any
too no further discussion when ready the
um motion before us is pass on House
Bill
177 seconded um move by The Chair
seconded by the ranking member when you
are ready please call the
role chairman Pearson
yes representative D Simone absent
presently representative race is absent
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
sidel yes representative love yes
representative coren yes representative
marel yes representative patrino yes
representative
Shore yes representative
Levesque yes representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes
133 to Z the motion
passes and this ends the exec session on
177 let's take about a five minute
break go to consent oh yes dear what
what what what what I would love that on
consent would anybody else love it on
consent with me great thank you it goes
on
consent
e
I open the exact session on House Bill
320 an act relative to enforcement of
marital property settlements and the
chair recognizes representative marel
for a motion uh thank you Mr chairman
yes um on this bill I would move that it
ought to pass ought to pass and anyone
and representative Martel would you like
to convince us okay well um what this
bill does is basically it require as the
law stands right now there is no
requirement that a court actually
enforce its own orders relative to
property settlements and divorce under
RSA
458 I think it's 16 a uh what this bill
does is set out measurable standards by
which enforcement is required or to put
the parties uh in the event an
enforcement or contempt action is
brought and what this does is is that it
puts in measurable standards by which
the parties in a court can understand
whether an enforcement uh enforcement is
warranted either in whole or in part uh
and whether any portion of the um either
agreement or court order decree is
unenforceable for any of the specified
reasons uh the specified reasons include
but are not limited to invalidity due to
duress Mutual mistake fraud deceit uh
material non-disclosure coercion and or
impossibility uh or illegality of
subject matter um if for some reason it
cannot be enforced exactly as written
what the bill does is provide that the
court can can create remedies that will
put the party in the position as if the
decree were fully were to be fully
performed and the other nice thing about
it is is that it lives out clear since
we've repeatedly heard that uh
Approximately 80% of the representative
people who people who are in the Family
Division are one of them is
unrepresented what this bill is it lays
out the standards by which somebody can
effectively plead their case um and
finally what it does is is that it
provides a measurable yard stick uh in
the event an appeal is
necessary so once again I'm going to ask
that the committee vote to ought to pass
thank
bill hearing
none the motion is on House Bill 320
relative to enforcement of marital
property settlements moved by
representative marel seconded by
representative Georges and when ready a
clerk
may call a rooll chairman Pearson yes
representative D Simone
yes representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
sidel yes representative love yes
representative coren
yes representative Petrino
yes representative Shaw yes
representative lves yes representative
Greg yes representative
Raymond representative George yes and
representative
Malone is not here 14
nothing 14 to nothing the chair calls on
representative Greg for a
reminder well this has an FN so I don't
or I don't believe it can is it an early
bill I don't have that I don't know chat
sorry well let's say it does until they
it from our hands
okay consent consent unless they take it
away from
right and now I open the exec session on
335 an act requiring the courts to order
a minor and their should be his or her
family to have psychological evaluations
and if necessary counseling where
parental rights and responsibilities are
contested in a family court matter chair
recognizes representative marel for a
motion thank you Mr chair um I move that
this bill be deemed EXP itl exped
inexpedient to legislate thank
you and uh I'm going to suggest
representative Raymond I saw her hand
first I've worked all summer at trying
to see her hand and there it
[Laughter]
was representative marel defense of your
motion please okay um my S okay uh this
bill if it beame law would require the
services of a clinical psychologist to
diagnose and treat certain in numerous
ated psychological conditions and would
require a licensed psychologist to
evaluate and file a risk assessment
report in 8 weeks or less there is no
showing that there are enough licensed
psychologists in this state who can or
are willing to perform this kind of
evaluate the kind of evaluations
required by this bill further this
bill's procedural requirements demand
that a court order a risk assessment
within 14 days of the initial Petition
of divorce and fails to consider the
large segment of children who were
subject to Parenting petitions and not
divorces so I once again ask that the
bill considered itl didn't expedi until
legislate anyone else wish to speak to
it representative Raymond uh thank you
Mr chairman I just to add to um Mr
marquel's concerns um I also have
significant concerns about um how this
bill impacts our bill that we passed
last year saying that um that any uh
Psychological Services ordered by a
court have to be covered by the party's
health insurance unless they both agree
otherwise and in this case um the risk
assessment that they're asking for
cannot be covered by Insurance because
it is not a recognized um service that
is provided risk assessment in
psychological circles terms means like a
suicide risk assessment it doesn't mean
any of the things that are listed here
um and then I also have some quibbles
with uh some Supreme Court cases uh that
make this potentially unconstitutional
so I I get where they're going but I
concur with Mr marel thank
motion the motion before us is House
Bill
335 requiring courts to order a minor
and their family have psychological
evaluations and if necessary counseling
where parental rights and
responsibilities are contested in a
family court matter the motion is itl
made by representative marel and
seconded by representative Raymond would
the clerk please call the role
representative uh chairman Pearson yes
representative D Simone
yes representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson
yes representative sidel yes
representative love yes representative
coren yes representative marel yes
representative Petrino yes
representative Shaw yes representative
Levesque yes representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes
representative
georgees
yes 14
nothing
you thank you yep I would love that un
are and so
um representative marel uh here are two
forms whereby you can take your
excellent defense of your motions and
put it pen to paper well uh Mr chairman
thank you what I did was give in my my
uh notoriously illegible handwriting
what I did was I typed them up and if I
was wondering if I can affix them to the
uh form I think the AIX is in yeah okay
thank you Mr chair pass them back I have
you this wonderfully ends our exec
next
up a lost
it did lose it did I lose
is open the exec session now on
HB
350 uh yes and please pass your
Amendment down I have another amendment
as well and this is requiring that all
Family Division hearings be video and
audio recorded and
broadcast live and uh the chair looks to
representative sidel for a motion please
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
to
itl move itl and I need to have a second
on that second is
representative
Greg and I believe this is where
amendments can be looked at is that
motion there was a motion but that gets
the bill in
play now we can have Amendment motions
for amendments yeah I think so um let me
pass them around so you can look at both
Amendments and I may not have deed them
up even
so this is one
Amendment that's rep they already have
representative L's Amendment uh if you
second all right make sure that you have
an amendment by representative love and
then you will be given a representative
uh cab Mr chairman we are several short
of Mr of Representative lovees oh okay
we have a Nana
yay thank you sir excessive celebration
is in
order I like my here's a pile of kabs
I'll swap you with kab fork you yes
yeah and take a minute to read over both
please
e
uh to amenda Bill that's already been
moved as itl is a Fool's errand and I
think that was a procedural problem on
our end up here so uh representative
sidal do you wish to pull your itl
motion yes I'll withdraw my itl motion
and uh who seconded that representative
Greg you wish to pull that okay so would
you now make another motion please so I
will move to OTP amendment number no
just the bill just the bill and would
you make that motion knowing amendments
are
coming yeah okay who will move OTP with
representative because we have two
amendments coming who was who will
second representative sidel's motion
representative D Simone
e okay so that's the motion on the floor
and now we have amendments uh
representative love would you care to
move your Amendment please I uh I move
I see no second I'll give it another
five
seconds okay this motion this amendment
does not
carry um and now we have Amendment
that okay representative sidel move
moves OTP on the amendment and who
wishes to second that representative D
Simon and just read it again what it
does is it establishes a pilot
program so that uh
the original bills
intent May uh be looked at I I am going
to assume that the ninth circuit has
approved doing this and they're not
going to wake up tomorrow realizing they
got got to do it does anybody know that
for sure or for certain sorry you know
that unfortunately we've not had
testimony on that so we can't we can't
assume that unfortunately we've not
that there is no assertion that this is
non gerain is
there no it looks pretty germine to me
all right it's just whether you like it
or not okay I would assume somebody's
done her homework on this
um otherwise it just just dies there any
discussion on this amendment
representative deimon you want to jump
in no yes representative Raymond thank
you Mr chairman and I appreciate the um
effort by the uh sponsors of the
amendment to address some of the
concerns that came out during the public
hearing um I think there was a good
faith effort here um I still think it
falls short of addressing my most
critical issue which is the right of the
child to
confidentiality um and so um just
because I'm not aware that many of these
cases are open but under on line 18
Section 3 says nothing in this section
prudes any person or media outlet from
recording a Family Division proceeding
according to existing Court
administrative rules or order
um and then it doesn't say anything
about um the dispersement of the
recording that a media or a random
person might make um and I just really
worry that this is going to end up in a
situation where we have children whose
information about domestic violence
child abuse their medical their
therapeutic records um any of that could
get out on the internet forever and I
just think that's wrong um so I can't
support anything that would allow
the recording and potential dispersement
information D
Simone thank you Mr
chairman we've heard quite a bit of
testimony Through The Years concerning
the issues of being able to uh
record um proceedings in family court
and the issues that uh constituents seem
to have with what goes on in uh family
court I think that the pilot
program can at least give us more
information to go on before we actually
pass uh any laws that say that it will
be in effect forever uh I I'd rather see
a pilot program happen than to have
nothing happen I think it's time we
address the
issue uh and help our
constituents representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman Mr
chairman I I thought that representative
Raymond did a an excellent job
articulating some of the concerns we
have with the underlining Bill and uh
which we at this moment can't support so
having a pilot program to test out
something that ultimately we're going to
say no to without significant changes to
Point representative
Sher thank you Mr chair uh I
can't in addition to what representative
Raymond said which I thought was uh very
thoughtful I can't support a bill when
we don't know whether the ninth circuit
has been consulted on this I I would
need even if I got over representative
Raven ramen's uh problems uh I just
can't we need to we would need to hear
testimony from the court that they can
this representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman so I think you know this goes
back I can't of course we're discussing
the amendment but it it really reflects
on because it's a pilot program of what
the bill States and so we already talked
about the bill and the complications we
have in these um in these court cases
and persons not always being their best
selves you know for things that can be
out there and I agree with um what my
colleague from nashaa said um as far as
those things being out there also this
right here under this amendment says
that these recordings made under this
section shall not be considered the
official transcript that really is kind
of the precipice for the people that
wanted this bill in the first thing to
have this official like document or
whatever so it kind of deletes the
purpose they wanted it for also it is my
understanding that um judges do have
their discretion whether or not
something is recorded already and so
there are certain times where people can
record in with their cases and that that
is an option so once again I think this
is part of uh the Judiciary Branch I
think that um what we're trying to do
here is put a heavy regulation on them
because of some high conflict situations
we've heard about which are just not the
um the greater um amount of them and I
know we like to say well one or two
cases could be too much but this is
really a situation where if they are
having issues with transcripts or um
recording or anything that that that we
have talked to them in our special
committee about that and how that goes
about and that's really an oversight for
them this is not something that we need
to be big brother with cameras in there
I would like to underscore what the
representative just said is that some of
the bills we've been looking at here
are things that can be addressed in
depth um in a subcommittee on Family
Court which will be
created anything else by anybody else
first second Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um I just wanted to say that I
think I know we're not considering the
the love Amendment because it didn't get
seconded um but one of the things that
kept coming up was wanting a complete
audio and video transcription and not
having the judges have the ability to
turn things on and off and I you know I
think that that's something that really
would get to the heart of the matter
more than a pilot program letting
somebody randomly off the street record
these things so I I still have the same
Outlet anybody else motion before us uh
is the the
amendment 2025 0441 H to House Bill 350
dfn the amendment is moved by
representative sidel and seconded by
representative D Simon uh when the clerk
role chairman Pearson considering that
the subcommittee can look at these
questions
no representative ative D Simone
yes representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
sidel yes representative love
yes representative coren yes
representative marel
yes Representative patrino no
representative Shore no Representative
lavesque no representative Greg no
representative Raymond no representative
georgees
No7
77 the result of the Voting is a 77 tie
which means the motion to uh of to the
amendment fails now we are back to the
original
Bill and uh my note say that this was
moved by representative Sidell and
seconded by representative D
Simon this is the bill without
amendments requiring that all Family
Division hearings be video and audio
recorded and broadcast
live would the clerk please call the
role what is the motion Mr chairman OTP
sidel and D
Tony excuse me Mr she pulled it and she
re oh that's right this is on the bill
and the motion was itl but withdrawn
right and now the motion is
OTP representative sidel made the motion
and you
seconded the original one okay then for
the chair is confused repesentative
sidel um let's back up do you wish to
clear the deck and start again start a
fresh yeah I wish to move House Bill 350
itl itl representative Greg for the for
the
win oh I love this committee don't you
love this committee I mean really I love
this
committee and excessive celebrations
afterwards are encouraged the motion is
itl sel and
Greg Clerk
please call chairman pearon
yes representative D Simone yes
representative
McMahan yes representative Nelson yes
representative sidel yes representative
love yes representative coren yes
representative marel yes representative
patrino yes representative Shore yes
representative Levesque yes
representative ative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes and
zero you know it's funny you should say
that I think so anybody disagree with
write who' like to write the committee
who would like to write the committee
once going
twice I've I've written a committee
report because I was going to make the
motion but I'm happy to let are your
rates representative sidel do it if she
wants are your rates reasonable to sell
reports um is there a rule that the
person making the motion has to write
the report no it's a threat more a
threat than
anything I like like my colleague Mr
marel I have I type something up so that
you'd be able to read my
handwriting she just I'll leave that up
to you I would you like to do it yeah
I'm fine to do it just throwing in a lot
of love since all the scratching away
over
here maybe I should we should just
let we should let uh representative
sidel right at that end she can just
steal from me or not what she wants it's
not stealing it's research
resarch okay Sidell
yes this uh puts to uh this concludes
the um exec session on 350 and bringing
up opening the exact session on 4:33
making
17 the age of consent for marriage if
either party is active duty military and
removing language regarding age wavers
from
marable registration record since age
waivers are no longer issued in New
Hampshire and would you like to make a
motion I would Mr chairman I move ought
this representative
sidel and would you like to uh both do
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
speak to my motion um this this bill
only
considers young people who uh young
adults who are in the military being
able to
marry we when we are in the military and
although I was over 18 I my husband was
in the military and a way frequently
during the first few years years of our
marriage it was very
difficult for me as his spouse to be
home with
children uh while he was away and he was
never in any one spot for any length of
time so I could not join him however
most of the time today um that was
during the Vietnam war but most of the
time today uh the spouse is able to
join um the uh military person and
continue their marriage during that time
uh and any children born of that
marriage would immediately as a rule be
able to meet their parent if we kind of
take a look at this and you see uh a
young person let's
use the the scenario that the male of
the marriage is in the military and the
female is the
17-year-old first of all the male at 17
can join the military with his parents
consent
um so if they were to marry uh the
spouse would have to if they were not
able to marry the potential spouse would
have to stay home possibly give birth to
a child who may not meet their father
years
because the spouse the parent the other
parent of that child can't live on base
with the uh the
father it seems unfair to the child as
well as the other person who may turn 18
within a few months
but I know for a fact when you're in
basic training you cannot leave the base
while you're in basic training so even
if it's a week two weeks a month you
cannot get
married so I I just feel that this would
create a an opportunity for good solid
families you
know the clock turns at midnight and
makes you 18 the next day it's not magic
that you all of a sudden become an
adult you either are or you're not that
magic clock doesn't make it that way
it's who you are inside that makes it
that way uh being married when I was
just months after 18 didn't make me any
more of an adult than I was when I was
17 I was a mature adult
period my husband was a mature adult
period I just think this gives an
opportunity to create good solid
families thank you representative
patrino thank you Mr
chairman so more often than not what
we're talking about here is uh the
female spouse uh under the age of
18 regardless she is still a minor at 17
years old she is a minor and that's
something I just cannot wrap my head
around
how we can support having children get
married regardless of any other
circumstances again more often than not
we are talking about a female under the
age of 18 A minor thank you Mr
chairman I might suggest that if this
bill were to make 17year olds child
Brides or Grooms it would also make
17-year-old child
soldiers may I respond to that please do
agree representative
Craig thank you Mr chairman knowing that
we just passed a bill last year that um
that just became enacted we haven't even
had a full two months of that yet and we
had a lot of deliberation on what that
was um and made the good decision that
we wanted to raise the marriage age to
18 um in this state we we've not seen
any complications from this yet as a
matter of fact the prime sponsor was a
happen stance kind of a you know a
madeup scenario that she thought could
be a problem we haven't seen any real
world problems from this um and so
knowing that we all deliberated very
hard that we came to good judgment that
the world is not what it used to be back
in the 50s 60s whenever people got
married a lot younger um I I think that
we are wise to stick with that until we
have real complications I also want to
say that having a service person who is
not married who has a family does not
mean they can't live with their family
as a matter of fact the military makes
it even for a single person you don't
have to live on base they have something
called basic allowance for housing where
they actually provide that money they
don't say is this your spouse or
whatever they actually give you that
allowance even back in the late '90s um
I knew somebody that was in the military
and they were just engaged and ended up
getting uh pregnant but they were able
to have this housing allowance off base
it was not a problem they didn't have to
be married so that's that's a problem
that we kind of coming up with it really
isn't a problem because the military is
happy to take care of the families even
if they're not unified in marriage yet
so I would say that we should ideal
this representative
George thank you Mr chairman um I know
the life we have today our all our
mothers or what they married when they
was young but today I saw a lot of girls
who are suffering not because just from
uh military but because to be married in
the early age but they never do anything
but they become a problem and uh where I
came from they give they make a a young
girl to be married but today I don't
think so because they suffer a lot um
leave make a 17 years old girl I don't
know but as a mother I'm not going to
accept for my children no that is not
helping girls we need to help our
children we are here to help to change
um to be the the change agent if we want
to be the best world we want to be for
the best future for the our children we
are the on supposed to make something to
make them feel better we already have
experienced ourself suffering why we
going to let again the our our children
to suffer because when you are 17 years
old maybe when you become 20 25 is going
to be divorced or they're going to be
separate but you never finish you never
do anything we the one you need to give
U um ready fature for the children thank
you
reprentative
LC thank you Mr chair
um I definitely don't support this bill
mainly because I think that this could
cause a lot of issues considering that
at 17 they can still back out of the
military it is a promise to go in and
then at 18 if they continue that promise
then they can join but they can still
back out until they are 18 because you
need a GED or a high school diploma and
you need to pass each military Branch's
test in order to join the military and
there is no spousal housing at basic
training you are basically housed in
bunkers with your trunk that you take
that are given to you and that is it you
are not given spousal housing until
after basic and my parents my dad's uh
veteran of the Air Force my mom was a
spouse and they always told me about all
their stories and I just remember this
one young girl my mom told me about who
husband gave her frozen hamburgers to
last until he came
back she had a mental breakdown because
she ran out of hamburgers and didn't
know how to cook herself a full meal and
she luckily had an intervention from a
pastor who the other spouses saw
something going on and suggested he go
over to her house house where she had a
full breakdown saying she ran out of
hamburgers a couple days ago and didn't
know what to do and didn't know if she
was going to be able to have food until
our husband came back because of his
extended
deployment that is what is the reality
of happening because we are sending
young girls who are
unprepared into a marriage I have
friends who don't know how to do their
own laundry I have friends who don't
know how to make their own Mac and
cheese at
I go to a college students campus at the
dry
cleaners see how many students know how
to do their own laundry it is
astonishing cuz not many parents think I
have to teach my 18-year-old how to do
their own laundry but it is the truth I
was nine when I went to the
laundry um mat near my house and a man
was surprised that I was doing my own
laundry when some of the college
students couldn't even do it at N9 so to
think that they are mature enough to
handle adult responsibility of their
spouse away on deployment on basic and
to be able to provide for their child to
provide for themselves is
astonishing and I don't think that this
bill is the intent that the sponsor
really
wants representative
sidel thank you Mr chairman I'm
questioning how are we okay when parents
have to give consent for their children
to go off to war to go off to to the
military and we're okay with that for
when they're 17 if they're saying you're
you're ready you're ready but we're not
okay to say to the to another child if
you're you're not mature enough to marry
you're okay to go to war possibly lose
your life fighting for your country
handling Weaponry that we will never see
in in the private sector but they're not
okay to make a decision of marriage
we're we're supposed to be trusting
parents there are parents that that we
can't trust to to raise their children
but I the majority of parents use good
judgment with parenting and I doubt very
much would say go off and get married if
I don't find you mature enough that's
where I come from representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman well actually the
military doesn't send kids off toour at
17 you can join basic you can join the
military at 17 with parents permission
but you cannot be deployed and it is not
a permanent enlistment until you turn 18
up until midnight on your the night
before your 18th birthday 17year olds
can change their mind legally in the
military it doesn't happen very often
but it is allowed and it's very clear I
mean you can Google it it's out there
it's very clear marriage isn't like that
you can't like two weeks later be like
oh this was a mistake and I regret it
now there's a whole process um and for
me I guess the bottom line is two things
one I don't think we should reverse a
bill that we just passed last year for
very specific great reasons and two the
testimony that we had here from the
women who H our current military members
who were married off at Young ages and
had such horrific experiences I just
feel like it would be incred I just I
can't listen to their pain and then say
well I think I know better than you
what's out there I can't do it so I I
cannot possibly support
this representative
Cen thank you Mr chairman um I I get
lost in the weeds here when it when it
comes to uh the fact that our state as a
whole has decided that it's okay for a
17-year-old to have
sex
um and that's perfectly acceptable as
long as the person's within three three
years of their age or what not it's
consensual um so we're okay with letting
them have sex but we're not okay with
letting them get married to me that
sense anyone else wish to
speak representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to does say that um this is a
very specific and particular carve out
that would um be utilized um very
rarely and also the very very sad and
awful um situation that occurred with um
that one woman in particular who was
married um at a young age to a military
person she told us that that person was
much older than than um she was and this
would not happen in this case in the
case of this Bill thank
you ju just to clarify nothing in this
bill prohibits representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman sorry nothing in
this bill prohibits someone of any age
to marry a 17-year-old as long as that
person's in the military we could have
you know a 75-year-old man marry a
17-year-old girl as long as that 75y old
man was in the military based on the
language of this bill I'm not going to
do it I mean I I don't think it's a good
idea but if the parents okay with it
this bill says that's
okay representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and to kind of like um reflect
on uh the weeds part of this and how we
have this consensual age at a certain
age and then we we rais the marriage age
first of all they're two very separate
entities so when we're talking about the
marriage we're only talking about that
we're talking about the ability to be in
a contract we're talking about the
ability to be able to get Services as a
minor um which even though we have this
idea of unemancipated minor once they're
married we do know that there are many
shelters that will turn women away if
they're not 18 because there are
liabilities within this so that's this
is more of a legal nature yes you know
the choices that that we all make when
we're younger can be um complicating
however this is about legally binding
documents we literally just passed this
bill I mean this has been something that
um representative has worked on for a
very long time we were you know looked
at as really making a forward effort
because we understood too that in a day
and age when we have much more um worry
about sex trafficking and everything
else we did not want to be a beacon for
this for people to say oh well I can go
here and marry a minor um there were a
lot of things that went into this but
certainly if if you want to raage raise
the age of consent we need to look at
that at a different a different time but
this is this bill stand on its own with
the problems that it
has you representative deimon thank you
Mr chairman um I've heard a lot of
discussion and with all due respect to
the people who are very concerned about
this number one um I was doing laundry
and caring for my siblings when I was
six so it has nothing to do with age as
to whether uh you you know how to uh
ration your
hamburgers um the other thing that I've
heard heard is that um a person under
the age of 18 cannot go to a shelter and
the shelters that in the state of New
Hampshire that I called said they would
absolutely be uh accepted into the
shelter the other thing is that we have
young women who are leaving their
parents' homes and moving in with moving
into homes with men who are are older
than them and being abused left and
right the
cohabitation uh is of usually young
women who are less mature than the woman
who is going to make the decision of I
want to marry the man I am going to be
with that takes
maturity there is a big difference
we have to look at the very
few I repeat the very few women who are
going to want to enter into marriage
with a person who is in the mil military
we're not talking about hundreds of
women we're talking very few those are
women who are making a mature choice and
lest we forget the bill does
require written permission from a parent
or legal guardian it's not that this kid
can just go out on their own and get
married they have to have permission
family thank you Mr Speaker Mr chairman
uh we have one more Bill to exec after
this so if anybody has anything new to
add fine if not I'd like to move this
along no promise
okay um thank you you Mr chair um I have
been fighting this issue since I was 15
the military argument has brought up
time and time again and I just wanted to
say that I
have received so many stories I still
receive stories of people from the
streets I
W
just saying that their parents gave
permission for them to be married at 16
at
17 and they were married off to a man
that they did not love that they feared
for the however many years that they
were married and it wasn't until they
reached a certain age that they realize
I can leave and sometimes they have to
leave their kids Behind which they never
want to do no Mom wants to make the
choice between my life and my kids life
of that situation but sometimes there
are parents parents there are mothers
that have to leave their kids behind
because their husband is so abusive some
of them haven't seen their kids in years
and I'm just afraid that this would open
up the door of abuse and neglect when it
comes to these childrens that we do not
want in this state and also there is no
active duty military base in New England
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
433 making 17 the age of consent for
marriage if either party is active duty
military in removing language regarding
age waivers for marriage registration
records since age waivers are no longer
issued in New Hampshire moved by
representative D Simon seconded by
representative sidel would the clerk
please call the
role representative d
Simone yes representative McMahon
no representative Nelson
yes representative sidel yes
representative love
yes representative coren yes
representative marel
yes representative Petrino no
representative
Shore
no representative Levesque no
representative Greg
no representative
didn't come
discuss Mr chairman i' like to make a
motion to
itl representative
Greg ends a second to
it representative La
LC got to put all the letters in there
the
Lash and uh should this come out of tie
then it will go on with no
recommendation but two reports I think
I'm correct on that but there had to be
another motion since that one ended in a
tie the motion before us is itl moved by
representative Greg and seconded by
representative LC and um again put me at
the end and the clerk will call the role
that's
sorry like she said uh when the clerk is
ready please call a rooll representative
D
Simone yes this is itl oh I apologize
no
representative um McMahan yes
representative Nelson no no
Representative sidel
no
representative
uh love
no representative Corin no
Representative marel
no representative Petrino
yes representative
I mean yes I take it
back representative Levesque
yes representative Greg yes
representative
Raymond representative georgees
yes and chairman Pearson no which forces
a tie so I need two reports coming out
do I have volunteers
for the uh wish the bill
passed who would like to write that we
do need a report why look at that
through the wonders of Mo modern
report okay you want to do it you should
get this one and this is yours is it so
it needs to be signed and those reports
need to come to me for final look at
this who's doing the OTP one I am the
simony um oh madame Vice chairman you've
already done it thank you you can buy
these on the open market you know I know
it all right I will put this in my
Lookout pile and representative patrino
you're going to write uh no we already
said she you hi um are going to do that
with that that concludes the exec
session on 433 and let the house floor
fight it out open the um exec session
now on House Bill uh
486 which is relative to grandparents
rights and I believe the Bill's Prime
sponsor representative Nelson will make
a motion thank you Mr chairman I make
the motion a to pass and do I have a
Greg oh I apologize I'm sorry I did give
you another cl to help me
yes um just so briefly um this C the
topic of amending um this RSA came about
from one of my um constituents who had
um had um guardianship um of her
grandchildren um at different times
because of their mother's struggles and
when I researched it I found out that um
we have up to 12,000 grandparents who
are raising their grandchildren um
having permanent or temporary uh
guardianship custody and we also
realized that we have um a really big
problem with um substance abuse disorder
and we also know that although the goal
is reunification with the parents uh it
can be a bumpy road um for recovery so
um this bill really
just adds language that um enables um a
grandparent or grandparents to have
positive
consistent
relationships with the grandchild
because it's in the best interest of the
grandchild and it also um gives a little
bit of help with the judges um because
um
the word divorce um was being
interpreted several different ways so I
I helped um add a little bit of language
that will help um determine uh whether
um grandparents should have a visitation
or not also just wanted to make it
really clear that I also kept in mind
and very carefully tread on the fact
that I realize that it is a parents
constitutional right to uh make
decisions about their children and so um
also wanted to mention that this bill
was
um two um big parental rights folks in
New Hampshire uh did sign on in
supported this Bill thank
you representative Greg um thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to commend uh the
representative for work on this I think
this strikes a good balance with uh
understanding that parents should have
that um that first right in healthy
situations but also understanding that
grandparents um do uh and can play a
very integral role uh with kiddos so I
us is ought to pass moved by
representative Nelson seconded by
representative Greg on House Bill 486
relative to grandparents visitation
rights the clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes representative
D Simone yes representative McMahan yes
representative Nelson yes representative
sidel yes representative love yes
representative coren yes representative
marle yes representative patrino yes
representative Shore yes representative
Levesque yes representative Greg yes
representative
Raymond representative georgees
yes the bill passes unanimously 14 to Z
the chair calls on representative Greg
for suggestion would you like this on
consent why I would love it would my
friends love it too yes what has a
financial note well they can ply it from
our hands if they want it they may not
be early
oh let's say yes and they can always
yeah I don't have my chart on early and
late it's in here somewhere this ends
the uh exec session on 486 and it begins
our lunch break uh try to be back here
around 1:00 or so please thank you
everybody because we're going to be
e
another
latest speaker it's not not the same one
we got last week it's not Mr chairman do
you want me to pass these out
time
e
Packard and I'm uh the representative
from lender Rockingham County
16 and today I am here to introduce
House Bill
10 and to make things clear clear right
away this is the original version of
10 we have amendments that pretty much
replace the whole
bill
so
um hb10 establishes the parental Bill of
Rights and this is in response to
Growing concerns from parents about
government
children I have had so many parents from
my
community and from across the
state come to me and tell me
that they are the
ones that are responsible for the
upbringing of their
children the schools are there to teach
them the parents are the ones that are
responsible for their health their
upbringing putting a roof over their
head feeding them that's what the
parents responsibility
is the schools are not the responsible
party when it it comes to raising the
child they're there to teach a child not
to raise the child that is what the
parents responsibility is that's why we
Rights the amendment requires full
transparency in programs affecting their
children parents have the right to
access all records related to their
children's education health and safety
and ensuring no decisions are made
without the their
consent family is the foundation of a
free
society and protecting parental rights
strengthens that
Foundation I urge my colleagues to
support this amendment to reinforce the
parents and with that Mr chairman
representative D Simone is the one that
put the amendment together so and and
I've read it and I understand it but I
don't understand it like she does seeing
that she's been sitting on this
committee for a number of years and
instead of me fumbling through it I am
going to let representative D Simone go
through the amendment so everybody
completely understands it remember what
I'm I'm asking for is the committee to
accept the amendment when you go into
executive session and which replaces the
original Bill thank you Mr chairman so
ordered
thank you Mr chairman and
committee Deborah D Simone I represent
Rockingham County district 18
Atkinson I'm kind of new at this um this
is my ninth
term so I've only been at it for 17
years and I say that kind of tongue and
cheek because um parents have been at it
a lot longer than
I um when I
read um House Bill
10 and the
other parental Bill of Rights bills that
past I really became very concerned that
we have not been able to pass a bill and
I went over every single word every
period every comma every T has been
crossed the purpose of this bill is to
establish a framework of parental rights
regarding the upbringing Education and
Care of their minor unemancipated
children it ensures parents are informed
about their child's health well-being
and education while in school
custody I use the word custody only
because children are with Educators for
six or more hours in a day
where they are in charge of making sure
safe key provisions of this bill are
parental rights it's direct education
care upbringing moral and religious
training of their
children we all have different ideas
about the moral and religious training
of our children and we should have the
right in this state of live free and die
to do
that the parental rights to enroll their
children or child in a public private
homebased schools or other state and
federally approved education
systems they should have the right to
access access and review School medical
records school and medical records this
has been a right that we have heard from
constituents that has been denied for
years parents have the right to consent
to biometric scans DNA records and video
recordings it should only be by the
parental consent that that these things
take
place parental rights should include
yearly waver and consent forms in
schools for parents to
sign as a part of yearly paperwork every
year children are G being
given
uh uh for booklets to take home that
discuss their educational plan for the
year
their student guide books and they have
to sign
them parents should be given the same
right parents should be notified of
suspected
allegations Andor criminal offenses
children we move on to the school board
responsibilities we elect our school
board
members that we are their constituents
and in a state where we have um a a
constituent legislative body the school
board responsibilities shall include de
to that they shall develop policies to
promote parental
involvement children do better when
their parents are
involved they should provide information
on course content clubs and
activities again children do better when
their parents are
involved it should allow parents
caregiver or caregivers to object to
certain instructional materials and have
the right to withdraw their children
from certain health education programs
that they seem they deem unnecessary or
not to coincide with their moral or
the Schoolboard responsibility should be
to inform parents of their rights and
responsibilities in the student handbook
basis parental parents should have the
right to health care services and
require written
consent for both parents and caregivers
givers for the health care services to
include medical procedures except in
emergencies all parents should be able
to decide whether their child receives
certain medical procedures or
not as far as a fiscal
impact um the fiscal fiscal impact is
not really to be part of the general
talking points to the caucus because it
it's really not necessary to to include
that there should be no new funding or
positions authorized there's an inter
indeterminable increase in state
expenditures due to potential increase
in legal
complaints and appeals so these changes
that I've made to
um the original House Bill 10 I wanted
you to all have them because it really
tightened up the language it gives
parents the rights to parent their
children that should never be
questioned thank you for your time Mr
chairman will you accept questions
absolutely is it true that this current
amendment is in part in response to
concerns that people had had with the
original bills so that the intent is to
Bill yes Mr chairman I mean I I filed
that bill initially so that we could
take a look at it and analyze it and
come up with an amendment you know I
didn't know if we have to change the
whole thing at the time or change pieces
of it uh it it seems that we've um I
know representative D Simone and others
on this committee yourself included have
worked for a a lot put a lot of hours
into doing this and um so that's
um where we're at um the original Bill
had flaws I think those flaws are being
of one of my day jobs is being part-time
CEO of a medical center and my wife is a
family practice physician and something
that we have long ago disc discovered is
there is a lot of misunderstanding as to
what Hippa is and people sometimes
whether they know they're doing it
intentionally or not will say oh I
cannot tell you because of HIPPA um this
question is to either one of you has
that been your experience that um Hippa
is invoked perhaps
inappropriately uh honestly Mr chairman
my daughter graduated from high school
quite a few years ago and it was uh kind
of preh hipper so uh I uh I personally
have not been affected by it I I cannot
speak for representative nimon but uh uh
I if I correct it wasn't around when uh
school if I may uh I'm in the same boote
as Mr Speaker
um uh with all due expect to Mr Speaker
there's more snow on my roof than his so
my children um weren't involved in the
Hippa but my grandchildren are and
uh I would
not be amenable to somebody not giving
my daughter and
son-in-law both my daughters and
sons-in-law information about my
grandchildren and their health care it
it just isn't right and uh
representative
marel I was just trying to look it up
but it is in the amendment
um representative marel uh worked on
verbiage to
um
allow for um this bill to Encompass
verbiage to give parents the right to
have their children's um medical records
them representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Speaker and
Madame Vice chair for um explaining the
amendment and the bill I I have a couple
questions so I'll try to do one and then
do a follow-up so is this only trying to
codify uh parental rights because I
actually everything that you said I've
been able to do with my own children's
upbringing without having this codified
but is this just codifying for public
schools or is it also in private like
these parents what I'm seeing is the
parents have the rights
in uh Public Schools you're giving it
that but not in the private school
settings is that correct or does this
somehow it will extend to both it will
extend to public private and religious
schools okay followup followup thank you
for the followup also it says that um
when you're talking about what uh
parents will be able to get it says this
is on page this new amendment I think
I'm I hope I'm on the right Amendment uh
page four line
14 it says the right of a parent to
inspect School District instructional
materials the way that it's worded um
the right of a parent but not the parent
does this mean because I know that we've
had certainly we've had an uptick in
people complaining to school boards in
the last years but they tend to travel
there are some that will travel all over
the state so does this mean any parent
can go to any school and start to
request this information it it does not
it means that a parent in and the reason
that I use that is that there as we know
families come in all shapes and sizes
nowadays uh and they may be one or more
parents in the home so it doesn't have
to be both parents it doesn't have to be
one parent or the other it could be a
parent follow up but the the way that
I'm reading it because because the law
is so specific and the gray area always
goes you know to the wrong side here so
it just says the right of a parent not
like the parent of the student or
particular student it just says the
right of a parent so what I'm reading
this too is that I'm just looking at the
the big ramifications and maybe
unintended consequences that this could
be any parent so I'm a parent so I can
go up to North Country and say what are
you guys doing here or you know in the
South like start comparing and stuff I'm
just wondering if you plan to specify
that
more so actually you could what if
you're trying to move to the North
country and you want to check out the
school system you want to go in and you
want to say I am a
parent of a stu of a potential student I
want to know what your curriculum
is other questions representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you both for being here and taking
my question um I noticed that um there
was a lot of changes from last year and
I sincerely appreciate all of the work
that has been done um I still have a
question about the medical records
section because we have another bill in
front of this committee about accessing
medical records and we got quite a bit
of testimony about um what medical
records are and are not um accessible to
parents under both New Hampshire
statutes and federal statutes so my
question question is how does this new
paragraph um intersect with the the laws
that we currently have on the books that
say that once you're 14 and older you
can voluntarily consent for STDs um
that's uh RSA 141 c18 and the ones that
say that um you know that that
children's uh therapeutic records are
deemed confidentiality confidential and
the Supreme Court case is saying that
parents don't have the right to wave
confidentiality for their child in those
cases so how does this language on page
two starting at number 19 of the
amendment um intersect with those
level
well um it does intersect uh because if
you apply and and representative marel
can answer this in Legally Le better
than I uh and he was my consultant on
this uh as um Mr Speaker stated I
consulted many many experts so how this
intersects is
that uh at
Birth a parent can uh file the paperwork
and and representative marel can correct
wherever I Stray on this to become a
child representative marel thank you Mr
chairman for taking my my question I
guess this is going to be way of a
supplemental answer perhaps um one of
the things and and by the way to
directly address your your your question
you're raised some good points because
there are inherent conflicts in the law
when you're dealing with child's records
I think one of the lead cases you may be
interested in is in re Berg it's from uh
2005 it's a New Hampshire Supreme Court
case okay and it deals with the
confidentiality of children's records
okay uh bear in mind that very few
things in law at least in my experience
as an attorney are absolute okay and
when you're dealing in a situation where
there's either going to be uh a custody
battle or there's a competing State
interest which is exactly what Berg
deals with and the accessibility of
Records what it says that the key
Holdings in regard to what you have
there is is that children have a right
to have a therapeutic privilege under
rsa3 I think it's 330 A2 I think and
what it said was is that the the
privilege the privilege um relationship
in terms of in terms of privilege okay
children can qualify for that so if
you're dealing in an adverse situation
or where there's going to be custody
issues or things like that the state can
step in and exercise that competing
interest and can deny parents access to
those records now that said that is not
all the time that's if you're in a court
situation I mean bear in mind that
parental rights are not absolute so for
example if you are in a situation where
you're in an intact family there are no
custody proceedings no divorces no
parenting petitions things like that
these are Under normal circumstances
where you would be able to access those
those records so um that right only gets
reduced and the competing State interest
comes into into play basically in three
areas one if there's going to be
allegations of abuse or neglect because
you do not have the right to abuse or
neglect your child number two is is that
if you voluntarily invite the state in
which means that you either are not
married and you file a parenting
petition for your children okay or three
that you're married and there's going to
be a divorce proceedings then the state
can intervene and make sure it's
protecting the interests of the children
so these apply generally and so when you
look also specifically at the terms
personal Representatives when you look
at hipa okay hipa is not in my reading
is not preemptive which means it does
not occupy the entire field of law as
your question accurately points out
because there are other state statutes
so when you look at that this basically
says a parental parental rep
representation as the child's
representative should under many
circumstances be able to Grant you the
access of the records and like I said
once again these are Under normal
circumstances exceptions here for
example stand up particularly when you
look at allegations of um law
enforcement investigation a crime
committed against a child or for example
if there is going to be something along
the lines of a court order which limits
that access now all that said to show
you exactly how convoluted this this is
trying to make it simple because it
because nothing in law is going to be
simple for the most part so when you
look at it for example if you have a
guardian at Liam come into a case Okay
where somebody is appointed to represent
the best interest of the children and
there may be therapeutic or Physicians
records that otherwise would be
privileged nevertheless a court can have
the authority to allow a guardian adem
to wave the child's privilege and be
able to obtain the records so the
concise answer is this would be
applicable most of the time okay but not
all of the time representative Raymond
followup uh thank you thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you for the
clarity so to believer the point a
little bit this makes an exception for
if there is a crime an investigation of
a crime committed against the child what
about those situations that we heard
about in testimony last year about the
medical records where a a child is in is
is telling her medical provider like if
you tell my mom or my dad that I have
asked for birth control I'm thinking a
16 or 17y old this is going to result in
me being abused or neglected at home in
the P currently as it stands the um
physician would then possibly make a DCF
report but also you know hold on to
those records until DCF does its job
under this I don't see a carve out for
the physici to be able to say I have an
allegation that has caused me to be
concerned enough to call DCF can I hold
this record until I get that because I
don't it's not bad enough to call the
cops because it hasn't happened yet but
it's bad enough that they their mandated
reporter law kicks in is there like what
happens when you look at the last line
it says it's a misdemeanor at that point
for the position to say whoa slow down
let's let DCF talk to the family before
we release these records right well
representative Marquel in the
capacity of being one of the amendment
writers and briefly
okay well I don't know that this
necessarily addresses all situations
under the law okay there's going to have
to be some flex and some exercise uh of
discretion okay I can't speak to the to
that aspect as to whether or not they
would subject to criminal penalties
there may be there there may be other
sanctions that could be taking place uh
that arise within the context of
um of being a practitioner however um
the converse is almost true when you
would say do you think a parent ought to
know absent any allegations of abuse or
neglect that their their child is being
prescribed birth control pills that's
another question I think somebody else
is going to have to answer well I mean
followup I would suggest that the
federal government has already weighed
in on that and there are a number of
statutes that say no parents don't have
the right to that under federal
guidelines okay well the when you look
at the
cfrs okay um there are issues of abuse
there are issues of whether or not that
becomes private okay or not and that's
going to I think going to have to be a
judgment call and I think it's going to
need some further some further action
like I said nothing in this statute is
going to be absolute under all
circumstances and if there's a need to
be able to protect a child from abuse or
neglect that's a different matter
altogether thank you thank you for your
indulg
any other questions of uh the speaker
speaker thank you Mr chair thank thank
you Mr Speaker and representative deont
um in in I want to go back to
representative Greg's question on page
for the language uh starting uh with uh
uh line nine through
um um line
23 all of those use the
language the right of a parent and I
believe a representative Greg's concern
was I'm a
parent of I'm a let's assume I'm a
parent of a minor thank God no longer uh
but um uh and I go up to uh Coos County
to just look at their records not
because I'm thinking of moving up there
uh but because um I just as a political
matter I want to find out what's going
on up there I I appreciate that concern
and I'm wondering if for example uh on
line 11 on page four the right of a
parent to receive Statewide standardized
assessment results if we were to add to
that sentence relating to their child
would that be an acceptable limitation
on what you
doing I I uh representative
um I think that this is the second
rewrite of the amendment and if any
member has an amendment they want to
bring forward that is something that is
your right to do that so if you had if
you had an amendment that you wanted to
bring forward you can bring It Forward
uh you know during executive session
followup um the scheduled and announced
exact date for this is March 4th so
therefore we have two weeks if anyone
should choose to do this followup um and
and I appreciate that uh Mr Speaker um I
I'm just curious whether either you or
representative D Simone um what you
think about that kind of modifying
language I'm always open to certain
languages but I never make a commitment
till I actually see
bad representative
sidel thank you Mr chairman this is
actually um to address representative
Sher on page one line 14 it gives you
the definition of a parent it means a
person who is the legal natural or
adoptive parent of a minor child so
would that not cover your quest uh
follow up to follow up to her yes um the
way I read that is as long as I have I
am the legal natural parent of a minor I
can go to any school district in the
state whether I'm thinking of my child's
in that school district or not whether
I'm thinking of trans uh transferring uh
to that district and I can look at their
records to be a little too cute about it
just for the hell of it that that's my
concern I I I don't want just to open
the door to you know school districts
all over the
state being interrog getting records
requests for records that don't relate
to their child in that District that
and if I could ask the speaker and the
that if I I could ask the speaker and
the vice chairman if this would
materially affect the
bill um may I ask you what would
materially affect the bill the
definition of a parent Visa v a
school is cleared to say a parent of a
child in that school what representative
asking well Mr chair to the point of um
Mr chairman I apologize to the point of
um another representative's statement
the definition clearly states
parent means a person who is the
legal natural or adoptive parent of a
minor and I think that that uh clarifies
as far as I'm concerned again I will
reiterate uh Mr
speaker's statement of if anybody else
feels that it could be made clearer and
you want to bring another
amendment and that's your your uh
legislative right to do
so representative Greg just if if this
welcome oh thank you Mr chairman sorry I
already think you once this time no
would you like an all day thank you pass
can we just do a blanket it would be
nice okay you have one um I apologize
um thank you for taking another question
for me I just
am wanting to make sure because we do
know that gers and the law can get weird
and stuff do you think
that if a parent could go do this from
any school and this this is going to by
your um definition and stuff include
homeschools include um uh private
schools everything else so this could
financially be a heavy burden if all of
a sudden any parent can go to any of
these schools and start requesting thing
I I certainly am worried about the
weaponization of that we've had and
that's you know we've had right to know
stuff and and um it can get very very
costly with any of the schools
specifically we're talking about like
home schools and stuff like that if a
parent was could do that do you see
where that could be a problem yeah I I I
think this um you know the the
discussion of a parent going to a school
200 miles away
is um not realistic
now I mean let's let's be realistic why
would a parent that's in Salem Drive to
Berlin and ask for what Berlin was doing
if they never plan on being there I mean
you you can um you can
possibly imagine maybe somebody might do
that but I think realistically uh that's
not going to happen May I make a request
that we move off this subject because I
think the answer is if somebody here is
really uh concerned about that you have
two weeks to get an amendment to clarify
the language you to protect the fears
you have could we do that okay other
questions other questions seeing none
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
committee thank you Mr chairman and
it is a custom in the house that if
Representatives wish to speak they are
accorded um primary consideration and
with that the chair recognizes
thank you very much I'm president
Timothy Horgan from straford County
District 10 the town of Durham and uh
sort of a scary thing being the first
one of many to speak against this bill
um you've you've uh responded Mr chair
you responded to objections from various
committee members by inviting him to
submit an amendment I personally feel
just looking at the original bill and
the amendment the amendment was just
published today apparently so it's not
even on the General Court website so um
we haven't had that much time to digest
it I think the whole bill is so flawed
that I doubt that I can vote for even a
heavily amended
version um first of all I think it's
basically unnecessary parents
already have these rights and if we are
um trying to enumerate these rights in
RS say probably be more appropriate to
try to craft a children's Bill of Rights
obviously
children um children are dependent on
their parents so you can't separate
one's interests from the others but I
think the children's uh rights should
come first Chris timing just the phrase
Bill of Rights that's something you know
we're all in theory in favor of um
although there is a lot of I probably
don't want to get into too much but
there's a lot of uncertainty of what's
going in Washington DC about exactly
what rights we have which parts of the
Constitution actually apply and that's
obviously take his name from The Bill of
Rights US Constitution but that's uh
that's that's uh that's probably like
not really our concern we're in
conquered not Washington DC um terms of
the so in terms of the emphasis of it I
circled uh a few things one is there's
this uh you still have this thing in
here and why I give you I give the
sponsor Amendment the props for making
the bill shorter so that's they've taken
about a page out of it so that's
probably a good thing like this's whole
thing about um before any blood or DNA
is created stor close I don't really
know what the purpose of that is and
then also brings me uh and terms of what
they would be helpful representative in
when calling it out if you could give us
a page and a line absolutely page page
two lines 25 25 and 26 and that's
something it's carried over from the
original Bill what exactly uh that's
about I don't know and that um actually
brings me to one of the issues that one
of the things that's not address in this
bill is the right of a
trans students to you know participate
in school activities and to be allowed
to go to school in peace which um has
been um which has been just abrogated by
various actions taken um also there's uh
another admission there there's nothing
about children who are and parents who
are different in other ways so there's
nothing there to protect um LGBT
children you know lesbian or gay
children lesbian or gay parents uh also
even people merely of a different uh
racial category or different in some
other ways there's no protections at all
for the rights of those parents or those
families enumerated in this bill um they
do talk about uh sex education although
children you know children are are going
to learn about uh sex regardless of
whether or not you take them out of sex
education there's
some and uh there's also uh language
there about immunizations you have the
right you have the right to opt out of
imun ations which I guess you already
have but there's nothing in there about
the right of
uh parents who support immunizations to
not have their children exposed to um
unvaccinated uh unvaccinated children in
the in the classroom where nothing there
to tell them how to protect um children
from from uh from transmissible diseases
in fact there's um other Al those on the
other hand it doesn't address the issue
of mask policies either but that's or
other missions I just think this bill
is unnecessary I certainly uh look
forward to see when we have the first
when we have the house session day after
your May 4th executive session what
comes out of it but I see very little or
no chance that um a bipartisan
compromise can be reached that I
personally can support so just I think
the whole um I just think the whole aim
of the bill it's I mean it's
well-intentioned but I just just think
the whole aim of the bill is like not
head in direction that can get uh you
know the type of consensus that we
should have before passing a bill like
this so I'm um I'm inclined to say uh
I'm inclined to say just find this
inexpedient to legislate and you know
move on and mean I'm sure this bill will
come back in another form in a future
session but um I will you take questions
ask three minutes and you're well over
it uh any questions representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Morgan um I just have
one question would it surprise you to
know that almost everything in this Bell
with the exception of the medical
records um is already in state law and
there's a technical advisory on the
department of Ed's website yeah um from
August of 2022 that lists literally
almost everything including the RSA
there that it came from oh not at all no
so that's which uh I'll also mention
this bill is in not really the chapter
of the RSA so I expect to see it I guess
it's one about uh you know child it's
one about uh child safety law but it's
not in the I say about uh schools which
is also another flaw with it that it
mostly only applies you can only enforce
these laws if the school with if the
school is part of a school district so
that leaves out uh well private schools
obviously also Charter Public Schools
public acmy and also uh the various
institutions that have subsidized by the
EFA vure program so yes but I would
certainly believe I I I hadn't thought
of that uh advisory I think I did see it
three years ago but yes I would believe
all of that of course i' had a bunch of
other things I would also believe so
thank you thank you for the question
representative
love thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um as I read the the
New Hampshire state constitution and the
US Constitution uh I haven't seen any
any Couts or anything that says except
for
LBGTQ uh we all have the same rights uh
am I missing
something um I don't know but I mean the
uh was the state in the and well the US
Constitution although I'm you know kind
of I'm having about my doubts about what
the US Constitution which parts of it
are actually being enforced or which
ones have been overturned by executive
order I shouldn't have said that but
anyway yes but I think respect for all
people is something that's uh that's
always been a principle both the US and
state constitutions and of course
bringing the LGBT community that's a
relatively recent development but it's
it's in line with uh it's in line with
how
how our view how how how the American uh
how we view the rights of of people here
in the United States of America over the
centuries so and there's always been
lgbtq people in the United States anyway
thanks okay thank you for your
testimony and I'm going to address the
audience um we have a stack of cards
most of you have appropriately put down
time to space speak 3
minutes um I can't speak for others but
I'm of an age where after 3 minutes I
start nodding off so the first three
minutes are very important after that
but also numbers of you have taken time
off from work or whatever to be here and
if somebody goes way over 3 minutes and
then somebody else and then somebody
else it may be 5:00 when we close and
you haven't been heard and you've wasted
a time a day off from work so I'm going
to hold you to the three minute Rule and
at one minute I'm going to go something
like this and at two something like this
and um when we get to about 250 I'm
going to say wrap it up please and I'll
give you a little time to finish your
sentence and so on but I'm going to hold
everybody to that roughly three minute
rule with that the chair Rec uh
recognizes uh Mr David Trumble from
where
you and the hardest thing to testify
here is you have mastered it turn the
light on turn the mic on thank you got
it thank you Mr chairman and committee
members David Trumble from where I oppos
this bill for two reasons I agree with
the representative that everything in
the bill is pretty much in state law but
there's two key additions to the bill
that are not in state law the first is
that it adopts the strict scrutiny test
and it creates basically an absolute
right for parents in relation to their
children in schools and that's counter
to the New Hampshire Supreme Court's
latest ruling on this case in the case
of dovie Manchester School District that
was just decided in August of 2024 it re
involved whether or not school should be
forced to reveal a students lgbtq status
to the parents the court said they were
basing their decision solely on the New
Hampshire Constitution they said parents
do have a fundamental right to raise
their children but when applied to the
school setting this right is quote not
an unqualified right they said that the
Manchester policy did not infringe upon
the parents rights the parents had other
numerous self-help remedies and that any
interference quote with parental rights
that may result was not of a
constitutional Dimension the court
concluded it follows that strict
scrutiny review is inappropriate and the
trial court did not ER by applying the
rational basis test that's lawyer talk
but what that means is that on page two
lines 2 and three where the bill would
require the compelling State interest
test require that anything be narrowly
tailored in no less restrictive means
that's the strict scrutiny test the
Supreme Court heard a case on this very
Bill and say that's the inappropriate
test instead you should use the rational
basis test and allow the students the
schools to do their job so this it's
it's a good bill but it goes too far it
creates basically an absolute parental
right the second problem is the vague
standards about what's included and what
not included I I'm looking at the new
amended version page three lines 13 to
17 that says that parental rights are
more comprehensive than those listed in
the section unless its rights have been
legally waved or terminated that part in
page two lines 5 to9 where it says
including but not limited to so the
question is does the absence of specific
mention of the rights of lgbtq students
does that mean that that's not included
in this list or does it mean that it's
to be included in the unspecified rights
we've had this buil discussed and
debated numerous times with dozens of
hours of testimony it should be made
clear because if you're a school or a
teacher you don't know whether or not
you can or can't listen to a child who
tells you look I'm I'm gay my mom
understands my dad doesn't understand
what should I do about it how do I
negotiate this at home what is the what
is the school's obligation what is the
parents right there it's there's a
chilling effect on schools you might say
well what's the difference the
difference is that for lgbtq children
home is is not always a safe place this
is from the Trevor Project 14% of lgbtq
Youth report having slept away for the
parents because they were kicked out 40%
just because they were lgbtq and we know
that having a trusted adult just one
trusted adult reduces suicide attempts
by lgbtq which are very high high
incidents by 40% and the Department of
Education in the state had a on trusted
adult program this bill would run
counter counter to it so thank you I
guess what I'm saying is I agree with
the concept parental rights this bill
goes too far it creates two new rights
one it makes it an absolute right by
adopting strict scrutiny and two it it
says here's the list of Rights and then
there's a bunch of other things but
doesn't say what they are thank you very
much would you take
questions okay any questions uh
representative Lavin sir you'll have to
turn your mic back on thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question because
the incidence of su suicide is so high
in uh LBGTQ children or adolescence uh
don't you think the parents the one the
most important people in their lives
should
know I thinkk you for the question
representative love um I do believe that
parents is where it starts and what what
I did point out and and what's come back
to is that 14% one in seven lgbtq youth
were kicked out of their homes and
largely just because they are lgbtq now
for most parents they understand their
children they're supportive of them they
want to love love them and do anything
they can for them but there are some
homes where that's not the case and the
only place that that child can talk to
somebody is maybe their coach maybe a
boss or it might be somebody at the
school and this bill by creating an
absolute right 100% of the rights in
this equation you got the child the
school and the parent and this bill says
the parent gets 100% of the rights the
other two parties basically have no
rights that's out of balance with with
what would be healthy in every single
case
and I say that also too I'm a parent I
had two children so I'm not against
parents I'm just saying it's not always
it shouldn't be at that ratio seeing
nothing else thank you for your
testimony chair recognizes Sam Hawkins
do good afternoon chairman Pearson
members of the committee for the record
my name is Sam Hawkins I'm here today
representing Nami New Hampshire I want
to be clear from the outset that Nami
New Hampshire is not taking a position
on this bill and as an organization we
do not serve just individuals but also
families so as such we do believe in the
fundamental importance of that parent
child relationship uh we do have two
concerns with the bill however that I'm
here today to represent um I've only had
a limited amount of time as others in
the audience to review the amendment but
I do think these concerns are applicable
to both uh um to begin it is our
understanding under current law that
unless otherwise prohibited by law
parents do have access to review all
medical records relating to their child
uh in regards to the amendment I do have
some concerns that it seems that that
provision of unless otherwise prohibited
law by law is not in there uh further uh
this policy as it is provided in House
Bill 10 uh we feel does not fully
consider all situations where it may
potentially be necessary to withhold
access access to records uh specifically
we feel strongly there should be some
mechanism for withholding records if the
provider has a reasonable belief that
such disclosure will result in abuse or
neglect there have been similar bills
here in New Hampshire uh that provide
parental access to records I know one
came before this committee and that bill
saw it necessary to include a similar
standard to that by which a provider can
deny access uh if the committee is going
to add that in we do however feel
strongly that the standard used should
align with the standards in the state's
child protection act uh moving on to our
second concern I would again first like
to emphasize that the family
relationship is the most impactful in a
child's life but we also know that that
is not the only relationship in a
child's life and it takes a full
community of support to build a healthy
thriving adult uh as such we do have a
concern relating to the language of
quote attempts to encourage or coer
while there's no situation where we
believe it is appropriate for an
educator to coers a student to withhold
info uh we do believe that the way this
language is interpreted by uh by
students or by Educators uh may have a
negative impact on that educator student
relationship we know that some children
may approach other community members
including Educators with their questions
or feelings before opening up to their
parents this is not because that
relationship is less important than the
parent relationship or is not because
that relationship is more important than
the parent relationship but because that
relationship is actually a lower Stakes
opportunity uh essentially we have some
concerns that that language may be
broadly interpreted by Educators or
students to mean they can't discuss
it I apologize I bumped the button uh in
closing this may result in teachers not
being there for students when they need
them or students not being willing to
speak to teachers when they need to talk
to someone and lastly these
conversations are important Stepping
Stones to actually building a child's
confidence so that they will actually go
to their parents rather than going on
struggling in silence so with all that
in mind uh we ask that if the committee
Advance any Bill uh that s does this uh
there should be consideration of those
concerns and I thank you for your time
thank you so much would you take
questions absolutely don't see any
questions thank you thank
good afternoon thank you Mr chairing
committee my name is Heather roai and
I'm from marac and I'm here today as a
proud parent of a public school student
to voice my opposition to House Bill 10
um I did read over some of the
Amendments that were just brought forth
um but my biggest concern surrounding
this bill is the negative impact that it
will have on public school Educators and
the education New Hampshire children
receive in our Public School
I can speak that in marac we already
have policies in place from the school
board and District regarding
reconsideration of materials as well as
parents ability to opt their children
out of any curriculum portions that they
deem objectionable uh this bill is
specifically targeting public schools
and their Educators giving parents
procedures to object to instruction
materials based on as noted in line 26c
beliefs regarding morality sex and
religion or the belief that such
materials are harmful parents claiming
violations of these Provisions in these
bills may bring forth an action for
injunctive Relief and damages against
the district and take action against the
teacher including losing their
certification many of New Hampshire's
school districts are already struggling
to find Qualified teachers to fill
positions and the provisions and
penalties of this bill will increase
this problem resulting in a critical
shortage of Educators New Hampshire
Public Schools one of our amazing par of
Professionals in a recent school budget
committee meeting stated I don't make a
living I make a difference and our
teachers do threatening our Public
School Educators with a criminal record
as it was
initially written although amended it's
unclear whether or not they would still
have a class A misdemeanor as a result
of violating these Provisions um if they
are in unable to teach and earn an
income it's going to have disastrous
consequences if this passes educators
will undoubtedly limit the diversity and
inclusivity of their instructional
materials for fear of Parental
reprisal every parent has the right and
responsibility to discuss their personal
religious and moral beliefs with their
children they do not and should not have
the right to censor instruction
materials meant for all children simply
because one family or a few individuals
disagree or find it objectionable our
children should T be taught to be
critical thinkers who are able to
positively contri contribute in their
diverse local and Global
communities this bill will place an do
burden and strain on public school staff
resulting in an increased workload as
right to no requests and copying of
materials increase the district and
ultimately our taxpayers will have to
shoulder The increased expenses expenses
associated with these requests finish it
up please thank you our children are our
future and our leaders and they have a
right to receive a well-rounded
education I stand with our teachers and
our students and ask you to please
how chair recognizes Kathy Stratton from
the New Hampshire Medical
Society
house good afternoon chairman Parson and
members of the House children and family
law committee my name is Deborah how and
I am president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire I'm
here on behalf of our 3500 members
across the state uh who mostly work in
prek through 12 public education as well
as at public
universities um to speak about House
Bill 10 we were opposed to the bill as
originally introduced and um well I will
talk about the amendment in a moment one
of our big oppositions to the bill was
that it would class by violations of the
bill as a misdemeanor leaving Educators
and School staff with a possible
criminal record and fine for violating
something that had some pretty vague
wording in it where you could violate a
um right that was not even enumerated in
the bill that would be a big problem now
we find this amendment is an
improvement uh it did take out that
language so we are pleased to see that
it also took out the attempt to coers
language was very confusing we do still
have some concerns and um some of them
have also been already been mentioned um
on page two lines 5 through 11 um
someone already testified about this
earlier we do agree that you know the
parents obviously have the right to
direct the education and care of their
children and direct the upbringing and
moral and religious training of their
children but that is not an absolute and
unqualified right in all circumstances
when you Jose that against sending a
child to public school if every single
parent insisted they had the right to
direct what goes on in the classroom and
parents have different ideas of what's
supposed to be going on in that
classroom how do you
teach what do you teach when you send a
child to public school how we decide
what to teach is the job of the local
school board they adopt the curriculum
so if we could somehow maybe redirect
this to have parents either
exercise the opt out provision if there
is something they seriously object to
and or engage in the school board's
curriculum adoption procedure and policy
and materials adoption procedure and
policy because school boards are elected
representatives of their local community
and they do have um um committees that
work on this and welcome parent
engagement that's how we decide what
gets T in the
classroom
this piece of the bill could very easily
lead to individual parents trying to
micromanage what all children get to
learn in the classroom and that's not
right I don't think that's what you're
trying to do um we also have similar
concerns to the um line 26 on page C 26
and 27 about instructing M instructional
materials um certainly if you want to
review instructional materials I
understand time to wrap it up
that also um repeated request for review
every single piece of paper every single
worksheet every single example used in
the classroom has a chilling effect on
what teachers provide to students and
get okay we've finished now
um
boy I
questions representative love thank you
Mr chair and uh thank you for taking my
question would you would you believe
that uh on on primary day I had a
constituent come up to me and a member
of Our Town Council M and told us that
uh his 8-year-old daughter
was coerced or spoken to by a by by a
teacher's aid and told that if you don't
like being a girl we have pills that'll
make you a boy do you believe nothing's
been done to that there's been there's
been no disciplinary action taken
against that that uh teachers
Aid I I cannot comment on that because I
do not know the whole story and I'm not
sure that you know the whole story
either I'm sorry to say but you're not
in in the um invest investigatory
process in that school are you or in the
district or with the Department of Ed
and neither am I I did turn it over to
the Department of Education
so they are following the the process
and they will they will certainly look
into it um we we have certainly heard
from many places where they have looked
into
complaints representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question would you say
that there are procedures um when a
teacher uh violates their professional
conduct um that there are procedures in
place to uh address those things
accordingly that would be separate from
this legislation there are procedures
there are uh depending upon what the
concern is they are either employment
procedures or they are um you know code
of conduct procedures and the
investigation either starts at the local
level or starts at the state level but
there's a whole um series of procedures
that are followed and yes uh
investigations do indeed happen
frequently we um we do hear about them
all the time through their Union
yes thank
you now the chair recognizes Kathy
Stratton from the New Hampshire Medical
handouts well we would have looked at it
and not you so being a good teacher you
didn't
I remember the days when handouts we
always used to pick them up and sniff
them because of remember those ditos
ditos amazing how powerful those
memories are the sense of
smell yeah why don't you just hold on
for one little second before the clock
go good afternoon um chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Kathy Stratton and I'm the New Hampshire
Medical Society CEO speaking for the
society in opposition of Health Bill 10
on behalf of the society I'd like to
begin by reiterating that we fully
recognize and value the important role
that parents Guardians and Advocates
play in the care and treatment of minors
we have serious concerns however about
how the proposed house bill would
interfere with the fundamental physician
patient relationship and the punitive
consequences it would impose um for Med
on medical professionals who are working
to treat
minors speaking specifically to section
three that addresses Health Care
Services the society's position is based
on the premise that Health Care
Providers must have the autonomy to make
medical decisions that are in the best
interest of their patients the
provisions within section uh uh page
five uh line number 14 that begins the
parental consent for healthc care
services introduces specific barriers to
this autonomy specifically the first
point of the bill States except as
otherwise provided by law or a court
order a healthc care practitioner or an
individual employed by such healthc care
practitioner may not provide or solicit
Arrangement solicit or arrange to
provide Health Care Services or prescrib
medicinal drugs to a minor without first
obtaining written parental consent this
pres provision would require parental
consent before a physician could even
schedule an appointment for a miner such
a law would create delays in treatment
and potentially dissuade miners from
seeking care particularly those who may
fear for their safety or
well-being as we continue to combat
stigma surrounding mental health care
and substance use treatment it's
critical to recognize that additional
barriers this law would introduce could
discourage these vulnerable individuals
from seeking care resulting in life
life-threatening
consequences there are situations where
the protection of a Minor's confident
confidentiality is Paramount to their
health and well-being under the proposed
Bill Healthcare provid ERS would be
forced to prioritize navigating legal
and custodial complexities over
providing the necessary care to the
child this creates a direct conflict
with medical ethics and prioritizes
which prioritizes patient safety and
confidentiality especially for minors
with invulnerable situations the
society's position in opposition of
Health Bill 10 aligns with our mission
to promote patient and public health if
passed this bill would create undue
barriers to care undermine the physician
patient relationship and impose
penalties on Physicians and healthc Care
Professionals who are dedicated to
protecting and healing children we
believe that house bill 10 would have de
devastating consequences for minors in
need of medical and Mental Health
Services therefore we respectfully urge
you to vote in expedient to legislate on
heal spill 10 thank you for your time
representative Raymond um thank you
chairman Pearson and um thank you Mr
Stratton for taking my question um so
I'm trying to apply this section that
you're talking about on page five to
real life because I'm I'm a parent of
teenagers and so I'm going to give you a
situation that happened this week and
tell me if this um bill would change how
the process worked so my um 14-year-old
is having her wisdom teeth out on Friday
and we have um prescription she's
supposed to have a prescription
mouthwash that she's supposed to use
prior to the surgery and then for
several days after the surgery um but it
didn't get called in to the pharmacy
with the antibiotics so I called them
from my phone this morning and said hey
um I didn't get the prescription for the
mouthwash I remember us talking about it
I've signed nothing can you call it in
to Hanford and I'll pick it up on my way
home from the State House afternoon and
they said sure no problem we'll call it
in because we know that you your
daughter needs this and so I'm going to
go pick that up tonight and then she'll
start it Thursday if this is passed will
I have to now drive to the oral
surgeon's office and sign a permission
slip for them to write that prescription
for the mouthwash that we knew was
coming because I have older children who
you know I'm not an attorney so um it's
it's a great question because the bill
does State written parental consent and
I'm not sure um how that would apply um
you know whether your initial statement
of consent for the surgery would have
applied I I just I just don't know we
would have to consult with attorneys on
that um but it does create a barrier and
um you know I think that that's that's a
thank you for your testimony the chair
minutes good afternoon um Amry Banfield
parental rights Advocate focused on
excellence and education I do come in
support of this bill however there is a
glaring Omission in it and I want to go
through that um the parental rights bill
should be free of a laundry list of what
Democrats and Republicans want it should
be focused on parents authentic rights
to care for their children a student's
personal information is now a commodity
by edtech venders Power School released
a statement a short time ago notifying
everyone about a dat data breach
personal information on students
including their social security number
mental health information and other
sensitive data points were captured by
hackers but what most people don't know
is that power school is currently being
sued for sharing and selling student
data from the lawsuit it says power
school without effective consent
collects stores analyzes and shares
student sensitive data which it acquires
through its educational technology
products that it sells to schools and to
school districts the information Power
School takes from students is virtually
unlimited uh it's 87 Pages I've read
most of it I would suggest you do I will
send you the link edtech vendors are
collecting very specific data and claim
that they own the intellectual property
of these students that means that they
are also storing emails in child that
the child sends and receives so
everybody in the world can access the
student information but for some reason
parents can't isn't that interesting if
you have children using a school issued
Chromebook where they access all of the
Ed technnology good luck this is how
they also develop a psychological
profile on children there was an article
in the Wall Street Journal several years
ago from a medical professional in New
Hampshire and it's called have you seen
Junior's psych profile and that is
because of the vendors that are
collecting all of this Behavior mental
health
information why are we allowing a school
or institution to claim ownership of my
child's intellectual property can you
even describe what that means data is
gold to data Brokers and on the web
they're the technology with the for the
technology companies none of this should
be shared sold or even accessed without
parental
consent in addition to what was brought
up data sharing used to be illegal 10
years ago you couldn't do this but it's
legal now because there's a loophole in
in student Privacy Law so this this kind
of legislation is good going forward
that's why it is
needed uh every student succeed act
requires mental health professionals in
the school to obtain consent from
parents on me Mental Health Services or
assessments so if that's a chilling
effect guess what people in our school
are are breaking federal law because
they should be doing it already so if
parent locks or if a child walks up to a
teacher and begins CH chatting about
their mental health information that
teacher should be get
parental consent it's in federal law
wrap it up please and anyone can file
91a so it can be a parent it can be it
can be a non-parent um also the APA code
of ethics for for uh psychologists okay
your way over time okay thank
you chair recognizes representative
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Dave luno uh representing the people of
Hopkinson and Bo just m County District
9 but as I also like to say Granite
Staters from every corner of uh of our
wonderful State because what we've got
before us today is a bill that affects
all of us and we all have statewide
responsibilities so I just want to get
to um get to one um uh one piece and and
just to lay the groundwork a little bit
one of the very last things the last
legislature did before um breaking in
December was to uh was to approve
changes to what are called The Ed 306
rules and I spent 12 years on a school
board and I never heard of the Ed 306
rules but these are the rules that set
the minimum academic standards um for uh
for all of our Public Schools across the
state and so one of the things that
really became obvious during this um
during this work is that um is that the
rules that had been had been in place
for the last decade were replaced with
rules that have been around in some
cases more than 20 years
so what we're looking at now as minimum
standards minimum state standards for
schools are really low standards and in
some case no
standards standards for superintendents
were eliminated standards for school
business officers were were eliminated
and standards for curriculum and
instruction were changed and watered
down so so heavily uh they don't even
resemble what is being taught in schools
today so it's an unfortunate Hallmark of
the New Hampshire Department of
Education the commissioner and the state
board so I'm specifically looking at
page four lines 36 and 37 where where
it's it says in the in the in the um
Bill of Rights
that you have the right and expectation
that academic curriculum taught in your
child School align with state with New
Hampshire and federal law
well we're really lucky because New
Hampshire public schools are some of the
best in the country and our students
perform among the best in the country
and it's because of that local control
local curriculum and and and high
expectations that our voters in every
District in the state have and why do we
know that to be the case because every
year they open up their pocketbooks and
and fund their school districts because
the state of New Hampshire doesn't fund
them voters have high expectations for
our schools and high expectations for
students I'm concerned that these two
lines will change that so um appreciate
your
consideration any questions for
representative
luno representative Raymond uh thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
luno so I just want to make sure I
understand your testimony are you
concerned that this line C on uh line 36
will override local control of the
standards and end up in a situation
where the state is now determining it
instead of the local school boards I I
am concerned um concerned about that and
especially when um when nearly every
school in the state is um um you know is
is utilizing academic curriculum that uh
that that is is upto-date
effective and puts our students in a in
a position where they're where they're
competitive not just nationally but
globally and uh and and this is
important this is why our students do so
well um I'm just concerned that um that
that having the expectation that um that
the curriculum taught in your child
schools aligns with with these low
standards um uh adopted recently by the
state are just going to uh hurt our
kidses great thank thank you
representative chair recognizes I
Hill and please turn on your
mic yeah that's the hard part the rest
is easy here
good afternoon Representatives my name
is Zoe Hill I am a resident of Lebanon
and I am here to testify in opposition
to
hb10 if passed this bill will take away
safe spaces for for children outside the
home sadly some children's homes are not
safe and that is why it is so important
for these spaces to exist outside the
home like in schools and in
hospitals and when children do not have
people to talk to about their mental
health and their feelings and anything
that they are facing their mental health
can deteriorate even leading to the
point of self harm and ending their own
lives a vote inexpedient to legislate is
a vote for children's mental health
thank you and thank you representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman I didn't ask
if you would take a question would you
take a question question representative
Greg and thank you Zoe would you believe
that we are very honored you came to
speak for us and thank you for being so
brave thank you you were given three
minutes you took a minute and 20 seconds
next time you get back you got come back
here you got a minute and 40 extra I owe
thank you for leaving the mic on for me
Zoe good afternoon committee members
thank you for taking the time to hear
public comments on this bill today my
name is Sarah Terell I'm a lifelong
resident of New Hampshire and the proud
parent of two wonderful children my son
is 18 and thriving in his first year of
college my daughter is 16 and a
dedicated High School sophomore I'm here
today because I have serious concerns
about this so-called parental Bill of
Rights at its core this bill assumes
that parents in schools are at odds that
they require government micromanagement
to work together effectively but that
simply isn't true parents and Educators
already collaborate every day to support
children's learning and wellbeing this
bill does not strength strengthen those
relationships it undermines them more
specifically I'm deeply troubled by the
provisions that could force schools to
disclose a student's lgbtq identity
before they are ready when my daughter
came out to me it was in a moment of
immense trust and vulnerability I could
see the anxiety on her face even though
she had no reason to doubt our love she
was still afraid of how her father and I
might react that moment belonged to her
to our family if someone at her school
had taken that decision away from her I
would have been devastated no one
especially a child should be forced to
reveal something so personal before they
are ready this bill claims to protect
parental rights but at what cost it
disregards the rights and dignity of the
very children it claim claims to serve
not all students are lucky enough to
have supportive families for some being
outed could mean rejection homelessness
or even danger the government should not
be in the business of putting vulnerable
Children at Risk I urge you to listen to
the voices of parents teachers and
students who know firsthand that
collaboration not government overreach
is what truly benefits children this
bill is unnecessary harmful and
dangerous please vote itl on hb10 thank
you I will take questions if anybody has
any
and I owe you a minute and 10 this is
getting to be a trend I'm going to uh
take you up on that oh good you write
that down somewhere thank
Harrington hi thank you for allowing me
the time my name is Betsy Harrington
from Dearing I'm the parent that you
guys are talking about I'm the one with
kids in high school who wants the right
to know what's going on I'm the one who
looks at their curriculum and decides
what they can and don't do and so just
this year I have one teacher that really
likes to cross my boundaries on the
regular um and I try to respect her
vision and uh my vision of what kind of
education my child's receiving um so I
respectfully told her this year um
there's something called rated books.
org it's an organization that rates
books for uh inap age inappropriateness
and so she was sort of acting like she
couldn't get along with me because I
wasn't going to approve books that she
was uh giving the kids and I said oh
just go to rate books.org and if it's
rated four or five it's a no and just
respectfully it's a no I appreciate you
checking and and that's it I haven't had
to talk to her again about it because I
just set a boundary and that's it I want
to be able to set boundaries I want to
be able to see what the curriculum is my
kids are the top of their classes and
it's for a reason it's because I'm a
good parent and I'm in tune with what's
happening if I also worked for DCF I
worked at the prison for 10 years as a
sex offender counselor for five of those
and I feel like having been a therapist
a mom all these roles that I can say
that this bill is necessary I support it
and it's necessary good parents need to
have a right to be good parents and
you're taking away from them we already
have a way of dealing with bad parents I
worked at DCF and I know what it was
like and we dealt with bad
parents people called us schools called
us and we already have something in
place we need
these all of these amendments here and
because I read the whole thing again
it's a little different than it was to
start with but we still need all of
these I I'm pretty support I I could see
that changing a word from a to to the
might help help but otherwise I'm
overall really supportive of this bill
I'm the parent you're talking about and
please consider my thoughts of how I
might raise my kids thank you
representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for sharing uh your story I
appreciate that so I'm just curious as
to whether or not you would denied the
opportunity to uh review the materials
uh in question um and um if you were
denied the opportunity to have your
child opt out of uh those experiences
and and and lastly uh if that's the case
did you talk to the administration and
say hey look my parental rights have
been violated here I don't want my kid
to have access to these materials so
when I went to the school to talk about
the books that I felt were inappropriate
the school's response was we had no
challenge policy at that time it's since
changed based on my complaint but at the
time there was no way for me to
challenge a book I could only go to the
school board and say hey I have you know
issues with these books being available
they banned my children this was three
years ago my oldest is about to graduate
they banned my children from all
libraries that day and my kids have
never used School libraries ever they've
allowed thank you you may be uh
absolutely right um my understanding is
that uh the parental right to opt
children out of certain School
experiences already exists and if that's
the case in your instance then I would
suggest that your rights were in fact
violated and the school district had to
uh address your concerns so that's where
I'm a little bit confused because my
understanding is the parental right to
opt their child out of something they
believe to be questionable already
exists the parental right to uh have
children have access to certain uh
materials at school already exists and
if and if that was not your experience
and I would suggest that your rights
were violated and the school district
was an error I feel like my rights have
been violated another example is like
the survey that they give to all the
students every two years I opted out of
that they still gave that to my kids now
my kids refused and they still tried and
pushed and tried to give that to my kids
and when the girlfriend of one of my
kids came home that day to our house
that day for dinner I said how was it
and she said it was traumatizing and
triggering so I was happy my kids stood
their ground and refused but they still
tried to give that to my kids and they
still try to give my kids age
inappropriate stuff I just keep setting
boundaries do they show me all the
curriculum no I don't get to see
everything but I try to see whatever
they will let me see I do think that
this is
necessary F yes followup please thank
you Mr chairman and just one last
followup on that so if the parental
rights that we spoke of already exist um
such as the right to opt out of certain
materials at school and your rights were
violated as we've acknowledged then how
would restating those rights again in
this legislation take care of the
problem that you experienced because in
either instance your rights were
violated so how going to prevent secrets
to me and for me when I look at this
whole thing it's going to pres prevent
secrets and as a therapist I've been a
therapist I'm not one now I I really
think that that's dangerous I think the
parent child relationship more important
than any other relationship and that's
prioritize representative Nelson thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question I want to preface this by
saying I'm an assertive person you're an
assertive person advocating on behalf of
your children I I try to do the same my
question is do you feel like there are
um many parents who are not as assertive
as we are or who are comfortable being
as assertive as we are when it comes to
school
matters sure some are not as comfortable
as
me follow follow up please do you thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
followup do you feel like this framework
of an actual parental Bill of Rights
might um be very helpful for parents who
are not as confident or assertive as we
may be absolutely people reach out to me
all the time and ask me for help because
they know that I'm the person who would
show up and speak for them here thank
you you're
welcome thank you for coming thank
you chair recognizes I can't quite read
it all but it's James from
Atkinson if you were James from
Atkinson come on
please I want to you service last week
Pastor I know you
did oh there it is it was on my glasses
that's why I couldn't
sorry um so I'm I'm uh speaking on
behalf of supporting the bill and all
the sponsors who support it I started
off about 20 years ago as a father's
rights Advocate that's when I probably
met Deb D Simone and um that
expanded when I started to see the other
side of the coin I saw Ms and I saw
grandparents affected greatly by Family
Law and grandparents especially are
important to me especially as I age
myself um and now we've come to a
different topic about the same targeted
people which is kind of sad in a way um
but I definitely support the intent of
the bill I support your changes that you
need to be made given everyone who's
spoken before for me and I think you're
doing the right thing by instituting it
as a law because we've come to that
place where we have to
decide who gets the decision of the
child who's who's going to be deciding
for them when I was a child when I was
um advocating for children I I saw
clearly that a lot of them were um
um were basically ruled by their parents
and whether or not we liked what the
parents did other than violence and you
we have to support them but it's come to
a point now where it's getting a little
bit out of hand and uh I'm going into
bathrooms that don't say the gender
anymore so I'm a little worried
myself and so I speak on behalf of this
Mr chairman I'm open to any questions
and I'm hoping I'm short enough that
I'll get my excess time for the next
bill I keep a log um any questions for
the
gentlemen seeing none thank you you got
a little over a minute in the bank thank
you chair recognizes Karen leot Hill do
I have that right yes Ken Leo Hill I'm
sorry Lee the te is a little sneaky
because it's silent so it's Karen Leo
Hill okay did you have a relative in the
house at one point with that last that I
did not but I I'm a 20-year City
councelor and the former mayor of
Lebanon and so I have testified in this
body I wasn't asking your experience I
just knew somebody oh okay oh
okay well thank you good afternoon uh
Representatives Mr chairman thank you
very much for allowing me to testify
before you today I am here as a well I
am here as the executive counselor
representing District 2 81 cities and
towns in Western New Hampshire including
the Capital
Area I understand that the intention of
this bill it seems is to compile and
assemble all of the references to
parental rights into one place to make
it easier for parents to understand
their rights and I can understand that
that is a good
intention I do believe that there are
unintended consequences in this bill
that make it harmful I believe that some
of the language is vague that would make
it difficult to enforce and I believe
that based on all of these reasons
including the testimony of others
offered before me today I ask that you
consider voting inexpedient to legislate
on this
bill with regard to um
vague with regard to vagueness one is
that's been discussed earlier is the
definition of parent and whether that
could introduce whether the parent is
specifically the parent of a minor child
in a school um or whether this could
introduce uh potential challenges or um
uh interference by parents who happen to
have minor children but are not involved
in a school there's some uh there's some
vagueness there that could be
challenging to enforce there's also the
word morality which is referenced and
does not have an attendant definition
the word sex is also referenced um and I
can point you to the place it's on page
three line 27 this is where the word
morality and the word sex appear a few
lines above it the word discipline
appears on page three line 23 the word
discipline is also not defined in this
statute uh the mention the word morality
is not defined the word sex is also not
defined there's a lot of discussions
about what sex is and I think if it
appears it should probably defi be
defined somewhere otherwise it's
potentially ambiguous and could lead to
um questions about
enforcement we've heard from theic
Society about the barrier to care that
this bill could potentially present it
certainly is I think an unintended
consequence on those bringing forth the
bill I don't believe that they intend to
create a barrier to patients to miners
who are seeking medical attention
nevertheless we did hear testimony from
trusted providers that this could create
an unintentional barrier to care we've
also heard testimony that it could have
a chilling effect on safe spaces and the
ability of teachers to um to teach
children in their
custody as someone who experienced
violence in the home as a child I'm here
to testify firsthand about the
spaces for all of these reasons and more
I would encourage you to vote
inexpedient to legislate on this bill if
it is worth doing it's worth doing right
and I would suggest that this bill could
use some more work um before bringing it
to a a vote thank you so much councelor
will you take questions I
will thank you very much thank
gay frequent flyers you know you get to
know your people we don't get
points thank you very much for allowing
me to give my parental uh response I
think that this bill needs some more
wording adjustments which can be done
with uh by continuing it um but I think
the what what our previous speaker just
pointed out it would be really good to
have parental rights in one place
because right now it's in covered in
many different places in many different
bills so uh considering all the inputs
that people have come and been concerned
about some of which are unfounded
because we already have we already have
laws or we considering laws to fine-tune
exactly what a parent's rights are and
how to protect children when those
parents should be reported we're all
mandated reporters so I'm thinking that
if a child at school says tells tells
somebody that things are really going
badly at home
that's not we're not talking about
parental rights there we're talking
about mandated reporting so I think it's
a really good to continue this to work
on this bill to refine the wording so
that it's it's clear so that not one
parent could go to another school system
and say I want all your records uh we
obviously do go and use data from many
different school systems to put out a
report uh our schools are having some
real problems I was shocked as a
resident of Salem which is a pretty big
town not not
poor and the reports on the children's
uh
achievements um educational achievements
they're about
50% I don't know about you but that
sounds terrible to me so something is
the matter I know we've adjusted uh how
to to teach reading which is a basic you
know the B if you can't read well you're
not going to do well in anything except
PE even written tests you know not there
so obviously we're trying to work on
issues I think parental rights have come
under
attack and uh need to be written down
exactly what is okay and what a parent
can expect because you know nobody's
talking about the experiences that
they've had that were just crazy that
they didn't feel this the school
Personnel didn't feel like telling the
parent something that we would think was
appropriate so I trust I trust that
y'all can finetune this so it really
really will be a valuable tool thank you
thank you very much you have six seconds
in the
bank I think you've already given them
yeah uh before we go on to the next
person these were handouts that I don't
see match a pink card so they may have
been dropped off so why don't I pass
them around and if I over did or under
Beerman hi Nancy Beerman New Boston um
Mom of two teacher of 15 years with a
master's degree I am also on the rare
disease advisory Council for New
Hampshire I am representing myself today
and not the
council uh as far as the medical um part
of this bill I do have to tell you that
as a parent with a child with a rare
disease it just about made me very upset
when Dartmouth Hitchcock sent a letter
when my child turned 14 and said sorry
you as a parent have no longer access to
the portal and to anything that is with
her records I will tell you that is very
concerning first of all because most of
the doctors had no idea how to deal with
and understand her rare disease and um
my child did not have the understanding
still in her 20s still has a hard time
understanding all the medical jargon and
information and needs an advocate and
support to understand what is going on
um I was and I expressed my concern to
the doctors about the fact that they
were keeping possible information from
me about my child child um of course my
child gave me the password and the
username and I logged on and I was the
one that was doing 90% of the
communication because my child was
unable to she was that sick uh so as far
as a rare disease parent and any parent
that has a child that has any chronic
medical illness
keeping information from parents and not
letting the parents communicate with the
doctor can be dangerous the parent knows
the information the child doesn't
if you were 13 14 15 years old do you
know your family's history do you know
all the medical information do you know
other concerns that the doctor should be
aware of no you don't because you don't
care about that you care about just
being healthy and be able to um get on
with your day and not be in pain um as
far as a teacher um I hope this bill
brings back professionalism in the
teacher position um I don't understand
why teacher feel like they can cross the
line I was always taught that there was
a line and you don't cross it between a
f a parent and a child in 15 years of
teaching I had to report two families in
15 years only two families the way you
have people come up here talking it's
like teachers are reporting families
every day they are
not I am concerned that a New Hampshire
teacher tried to get custody of a
student and have them move into their
house recently that was very scary
situation um and as far as parents go we
do not give up custody of our child as
soon as they cross and go into the
school
building as a teacher I don't have
custody of that child that is a parents
decision wrap it up please uh finally
um teachers are not kids friends
administrators should not be encouraging
teachers to have
relationships with their students should
be a professional boundary thank you
thank you any questions for the witness
coming Megan Tuttle and Brian Hawkins
EA which is
what well it's for the record I know
what it is don't ask a question answer
for the record it's not the National
Endowment for the Arts oh I had a
project although I'm sure that's a
lovely place to work as well so um thank
you Mr chairman for the record Brian
Hawkins from the National Education
Association New Hampshire uh we
represent um K12 Educators across the
state um and we're here today in
opposition to the bill um I do have some
testimony that was based on the original
version of the bill and so I'll try to
just touch on the points I think seem to
be consistent with the the amendment um
so first um as was stated earlier we are
obviously pleased that the criminal
penalties were removed from this bill um
but it still leaves um it was mentioned
earlier where the where the line is it
still leaves some some vague language in
there that were concerned so that
Educators can follow whatever law is
passed from from the legislature um
house B 10 is stating that uh all
parental rights are reserved including
but not limited to so this leaves open
that there are other rights or
violations that could happen which would
cause the person to have violated those
rights to be it's not criminally
prosecuted anymore but um there is
language in there about a potential uh
discipline um similarly there are the
two uh issues that got that were brought
up in the front half of the list of
Rights for parents the right to uh
direct the upbringing and moral or
religious more I'm sorry I think I might
have bumped the button actually but I'll
continue I don't want to lose too many
seconds
here I always run out of time so uh um
so we're we're concerned that that that
is vague we're that's not grounded in
any
statute is just there and it's unclear
who would Define that um and so again
clarity about what we're talking about
um there are there are morals discussed
in school all the time um you know and
so um sharing and caring about the
community things like that so where
where what are we talking about when
we're talking about specifically because
it says the right to direct that and I
think some previous speakers raised some
concerns about um you know how granular
granular are we talking about there um
I've got to make sure that the some of
the other concerns that I have listed
here are still consistent with the
amendment but um as I mentioned earlier
there is a a reference there about the
possibility of disciplinary action being
referenced and so that that's a little
unclear about who are we talking about
are we talking about the school or we
talking about the doe um this is this is
unclear um and I'll close uh by saying
that you know I think someone mentioned
earlier that parents and Educators have
been working really well together in the
state for a long time and we ought to be
focused on legislation that's going to
help Foster that uh relationship and I
think that this um this um takes us in
the opposite direction the one last
specific thing that I'll just mention uh
I would just ask uh that the committee
take a look at um on page three uh Roman
2 there's a reference in letter B to a
statute uh that I may be wrong but
18611 Roman 9C has to do with reviewing
um uh the board with for the Board of
Education to review HIV AIDS curriculum
and I'm not sure if that
is what your was intended here it looks
like this
is is trying to uh have some protective
language around law
enforcement um so unless I have the
wrong statute uh or the wrong version of
the bill um you may want to take a look
at that and then uh we have the same
concern about U that Nami race about the
encouraged language and that that that
too is is is very Broad and subjective
so I'll close there and happy to take
any
questions seeing none thank you okay
thank you Mr
chairman chair recognizes attorney Ian
huitt from
Cornerstone and you have handouts yes Mr
chairman may I distribute these you may
marel thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee and thank you to to
speaker Packard and to representative D
Simone for their passion for parents
rights Ian huitt appearing for
Cornerstone and I've just broken the
first rule of trial advocacy which is
never distribute an exhibit to the jury
when you're about to speak but I want
see I normally hold to that but I want
you all to see what I am talking about
in my testimony and what I've just
passed around are the operative the main
operative Clauses from Senate bill 272
in
2023 which was the Senate parents Bill
of Rights the language you have in front
of you is taken verbatim from 272 in
2023 and this language passed the Senate
a a majority of returning Senators not
only voted for but sponsored this
language and it lost the house in 2023
by about five votes depending upon what
roll call vote you look at so it should
have no problem passing the house this
session the idea of a parents Bill of
Rights really came up because school
districts across New Hampshire have
adopted policies in which they
explicitly say that schools will not
only conceal transitioning from parents
but will affirmatively lie to parents to
conceal a child's transitioning and I I
can't really underscore enough how
bizarre this is and how strange New
Hampshire is in this area I've closely
reviewed viewed at least a dozen School
District policies on the area of gender
identity in Massachusetts and I am not
aware of a single School District policy
in Massachusetts not even Boston or
Cambridge that says expressly School
Personnel should lie to parents to
conceal transitioning like most New
Hampshire school district policies say
and I think this has happened because
National donors and
organizations like the ACLU and glad and
listen see New Hampshire which is a
competitive purple State as a
Battleground and a laboratory and
they're therefore very invested in
making sure that model policies are
passed in every single one of our school
districts the result being that parents
rights are much more limited in New
Hampshire today in the LI for your die
State than in Massachusetts so
Cornerstone is constantly exploring ways
we could challenge these secret
transitioning and deception policies
theoretically we have three Avenues to
challenge them State constitutional
rights state statutory rights or
politically through the general court as
you've heard about today the state
constitutional Avenue is foreclosed our
state Supreme Court held effectively
that parents rights are something that
the child and the parent enjoy in
concert together against the state when
their wishes are aligned and they
parents rights are not something under
the New Hampshire Constitution that the
parents have over the child against the
state so we have no more State
constitutional remedy the issue is if
the general court passed a list of
enumerated parents rights that did not
address secret transitioning that would
at least foreclose all of our remaining
State statutory remedies if not all of
our remaining avenues for addressing
secret transitioning so to be clear our
position is not we would like to see a
perfect parents Bill of Rights or we
don't want to see a bill our position is
that the general court should not take a
step that would put us in a worse
position with respect to this critical
issue and actually set us back in court
relative to where we are now so for if I
may one more sentence Mr chairman uh for
example if the general court were to
pass almost anything else on parents
rights like creating a parents Rights
Commission or committee we would have no
objection to that I'm doing the
punctuation just to see what kind of a
sentence it was thank you Mr chairman I
believe it was a runon sentence but one
nonetheless but thank you any questions
for attorney HT
seeing none thank you thank you so much
and with no more pink cards this
concludes the hearing on House Bill 10
it will be exact on March 4th so keep
[Music]
alone
yes
face I was just thinking this is going
some
e